yes so why don't we get started I don't
know how many of you uh heard from will
will is going to be a little late today
he has some business he has to do so
he's coming around lunchtime so I will
run the morning hearings and and then
we'll be relieved with with with Will
joining us
afternoon um before we get started
representative love if you could lead us
legance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
all all right thank you and with no
further Ado um I will open the public
hearing on HB
10007 and we'll ask the sponsor
bill
good
morning ready on okay there we
go um so my name is Mark McKenzie and
this is the first time in a long time
I've been on this side of the table
uh prior to that I was uh uh I spent
about better part of my adult life as a
a professional lobbyist in uh in New
Hampshire representing initially the
firefighters uh for many years uh and
then on to the AFL CIO where I uh worked
on uh a whole variety of issues over the
course of my career including pension
legislation labor legislation uh uh
workers comp Unemployment uh and a whole
variety of uh of issues and much of
which when I was reviewing yesterday uh
the before this bill uh many of the
placards that were refer to today are
some of the uh many of the uh pieces I
worked on um over the course of the
years so this morning I appeared before
the committee uh and asked for your
support in House Bill
one7 uh and it is a disc Begins the
discussion around the issue of remote
work and implications uh that has for
the
workforce remote work is something that
is growing in New Hampshire uh here we
are on the other side of Co and many
people uh many people have taken
advantage of of this particular um uh
you know option in workplaces around the
around the state uh I probably need my
paper over there by way because I think
I gave
everybody yeah I think I gave it all
out my test testimony actually thank you
so the question uh the question before
before this committee is uh is this
something we're going to start to look
at remote work and this is the beginning
of I think a discussion around it so
with this particular Bill uh does is
pretty benign in the sense that all it
requires is that the employer uh write
down what the terms are uh under which
the employee will work and to share it
with them there's no negotiations that
go on there are no uh opportunities to
appeal it uh it's simply a statement to
the employee now the employee once they
see what the deal is they have the
authority and the right U certainly to
say no this doesn't work for me and uh
they can either can either accept it or
reject it and move on so I you know I've
heard that uh there are many uh
instances in the state of New Hampshire
where uh where employers uh have this
written down and I give you some
examples of the policy but I think
everybody should if they're going to be
doing remote work they should think
about it write it down and make sure the
employee knows what's going
on now what we've seen in the past few
years and this is a handout from the uh
labor market brief is that the has been
a bit of a surge in uh in uh and if you
look on page two you can look you can
see uh how the uh how it's trending up
the number of people who work in uh uh
remotely is is is on its way up uh Co I
think is responsible for that but it
also is having impacts quite frankly on
communities uh there's some there's some
indication according to this report that
things are being affected housing prices
are being affected and uh and the other
thing is that it there is some evidence
that uh remote work has some
consequences for for the employees
overall uh in that they uh The Social
Network and all those kinds of things uh
that come up but clearly it's it's it's
here it's here to stay uh and I think
that the responsibility uh that we have
uh as a labor committee is to start the
process of looking at this so many years
ago when the federal government passed
uh
regulations uh they were put in place to
deal with homework uh so there were many
uh there instances in the Federal W now
that was at a time when they were trying
to prevent people from making dresses in
their garage or assembling things in
their basement and it was in many cases
it was uh it was hazardous uh so the
federal law was responded to that by
passing a legislation which basically
prohibited a lot of that stuff so so I I
think that uh but I don't think that the
remote work uh Arena we've caught up
with that is yet what um what I think uh
what I think makes sense uh for this uh
is is as we start through this process
and you're going to hear probably
testimony today um that we that we
really think about what our role is for
this that we think about how it is that
we're going to deal with this new
environment um because I don't think
there's much on the books to deal with
it now and the other part of this is uh
the other part of this is that that the
current Law requires all this placarding
of workplaces and if you work out of
your house then working out of your
house is uh is a workplace and as a
result of that being a workplace you
have you know you have access to work as
compensation you know wait of lunch
breaks of turning computers off of all
of those kinds of things but I'm not
sure either the employees are sharing
that with people or the people know that
so the what we have done over the years
is part of the law we said everything's
got to be placarded uh and and so I'm
not suggesting that we put placards over
your house uh but I am suggesting this
legislation would write the deal down
and include as part of that uh that
agreement that Arrangement that they be
informed of the of the uh current um
laws so that they have any pla cards be
distributed electronically to the
employees so they know that this is a
real workplace now one I was over I
started this discussion at the
department of administrative services
uh and they have a very comprehensive
program uh for uh for remote work and if
you're got to do remote work I mean I
think that's kind of the direction
you're moving in you want to have a good
policy in place to do it but one of the
things that really struck me uh and they
were they were wonderful they gave me a
really good uh briefing of how that
policy works but one thing really struck
me is of the hundreds of people who are
covered by M D services it was only one
they thought only one workers comp claim
in the in the entire Workforce
so that would be unusual to say the
least uh and I don't know quite frankly
I've served in the workers comp appeals
board for many many years and we never
had a case like that or very not that I
could
remember uh and I but I think it'd be
difficult uh though it's that though
they're entitled to workers compensation
it would be a difficult thing to prove
uh some of this stuff is connected to
your job sorting out whether or not you
fell down the stairs as a result of work
the work that you were doing whether or
not you got a backache or fell off the
chair or got CLE tunnel it's all the
workplace those are difficult issues in
a normal workplace it's different we
respond differently we we have different
um um you know we have places and we
have uh people that see it and and when
that happens many times people will
report it but remote work is different
and the fact that you have
administrative Services again who are
Wonder ful and they got a great policy
uh there was one workers comp inury and
they thought the entire Workforce would
be really remarkable and so uh so again
are the employees do the employees know
what they get they getting what the deal
is and again there's not negotiations
not suggesting that are they uh are they
able to get the pla carding information
that they they would normally get and
see in a workplace and uh and finally
they exercise their own rights whether
or not they want that job that's the ENT
of this legislation now I could have
gone further I didn't I decide not to do
that I think it's one line it's pretty
simple uh and so that's that's kind of
my story uh about why I introduced this
legislation thank you for your testimony
sponsor thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative mckeny um one
question I have is I understood
everything you're saying I just want to
get confirmation does this require or
will this be compelling employers to
offer uh the ability to work remotely no
there's nothing in this that's going to
compel anybody to create a work remotely
environment for their employees thank
you further questions represent stranger
uh thank you U I just have a question uh
so uh it says this act shall take uh
effect 60 days after passage uh is is
that an intentional decision or was that
just the default that was sort of stuck
with I I actually think that was a
result of the legislative Services
writing it that way but I'm pretty
flexible in terms of okay I we would do
sponsor seeing none thank you very much
for your testimony thank you I have one
card today so far uh from Dave juv he is
speaking in opposition to the bill
representing
Bia
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh Happy
2024 uh for the record my name is Dave
juv I'm a senior vice president for
public policy with the business and
industry Association we're a Statewide
trade Association we have approximately
400 employer members with over 990,000
Granite State Employees
um I had
to sign up in
opposition um I didn't feel right
signing up supporting
but in many instances I agree with the
sponsor I think this is relatively
benign I don't think it will create or
hamper um employers if the legislature
feels in its wisdom that this is a
problem that needs to be addressed and
passes the bill employers will will add
this to their list of uh notices that
they're already required to
do I question whether this is really a
problem or whether it could be a problem
in order for there to be any type of
remote work arrangement for it to work
the employer has to somehow communicate
how that's going to work to the employee
um if they're smart it'll be a part of
their employee manual but in in any
event they I don't understand how a
remote work Arrangement could work
without there being a clear
understanding of how that will work
between the employer and the employee
having said that um I think again it's
relatively benign and I'd be happy to
answer any questions the committee may
have all right thank you are there
questions for uh Mr duvet yes represent
real Qui yeah thank you for your
testimony Mr dubet if you don't think
that it's really
you know if you think it's you're going
to have that agreement with your
employer why not just make it so that
you do have to have that agreement with
your employer it's just protecting both
parties I think yeah as I said we I
signed up opposing the bill we're not
going to the mat on this one I think
it's relatively benign I don't believe
it's a problem here in New Hampshire if
you feel is the legislature it's in the
best interest of the state and uh
employees to get this far into the weeds
so be it um I will
say remote work agreements could shift a
lot from from uh the time of year to the
number of employees to the type of work
being done so it is fluid but under any
of those circumstances the employer is
going to have to make sure there's a
clear understanding of of how that
Arrangement is going to take place yeah
all right thank you further question
questions uh representative
kill thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
juv for taking my question I I think
we're in agreement as so often happens
that uh that uh remote work is a good
thing it's good for the employer it's
good for the employee and obviously you
can't do that if you're fixing cars in
the garage or seeing pay well so sorry
you can do tele telephonic seeing
patients but there's a number of things
where it's appropriate and really
practical and other places it isn't so I
don't know if the employee manual but
you know maybe sort of in the uh job
offer letter but someplace uh I would
agree that it would be um appropriate to
say this is how many days we'd like you
to be in this in the shop and how many
days subject to change you know so that
everyone understands and that it might
also help with our uh Child Care crisis
if you have kids that don't need your
attention every minute and you could be
working while they're you know there so
my question is um do you think that this
included with the other things that you
say that we employers and employees
should communicate about might be worth
our legislative time to pass this and
and include our vacation time and other
things that we should explain thoroughly
so that uh everyone's on the same
page um as I testify if you and your
wisdom think this is a significant issue
that needs to be addressed I don't think
it's going to create a huge hardship
among employers I personally don't know
that this is a big problem or how it
could possibly be a big problem but I'll
leave it up to your uh wisdom as
legislators to make that determination
thank you Mr
J representative kulum thank you thanks
for taking my question so um in the past
have you had experience where maybe
employers and employees have had
somewhat of a handshake agreement a
verbal agreement agement on it's okay
for you to do this and then somewhere
along the lines somebody changed the
changed the deal or misinterpreted the
the the idea of it so do you think maybe
instead of having a handshake deal or a
verbal agreement that maybe putting
something in writing so that it's pretty
clear and concise helps both parties so
that one can't come back to the other
saying that's not what you
said uh the direct answer to your
question is I am not aware of that ever
having happen doesn't mean it hasn't and
if you feel that it is something that
would improve understanding between
employers and
employees I feel this is relatively
benign I can tell you with my employer
this is something that is a part of our
employee manual and it clearly
stipulates how it will work so I suspect
with most uh more sophisticated
employers that have employee manuals
that also have some type of remote work
Arrangement I'd be surprised if it's not
mentioned in there but I have not
surveyed our members to find out about
that I am think it's in everybody's best
interest for that type of thing to be
clarified and and another thing I would
agree along the lines with what
representative kahill was asking and
what the um sponsor of the bill said
said remote work is here to stay it was
here before covid probably not as common
as it is now um it works for a lot of
employers obviously there are some
Hospitality manufacturing you know
retail that it's not going to be very
practical but there are all kinds of
other employers and jobs where remote
work is feasible and it's something we
Bia any further questions yes
representative
St my question is about um location um
for example my daughter is in
Massachusetts and they actually have one
of those placards hanging in their
kitchen and um but the company that she
works for is in another state so when
you are providing this um these this
information about um employee rights do
you use the state where the worker is
located or is it the state where the
company is located and how does that um
how how are the connections made between
the employer and the um and the worker
yeah I think that's an excellent
question I feel like I should know the
answer to that but I don't feel
comfortable enough to give it if there's
someone here from Department of Labor
that might be a good question for them
there's got to be some way because as as
we all know there are number of
notifications that are already in law
that would be impacted by that I just
don't feel comfortable answering the
question without being completely sure
and I see our representative from the
Department filling out a card so when
you're done we'll ask her to come up and
and respond to that thank you Mr
chair any further questions for the this
Witness
testimony and I'll let her go first so
she can respond to that question and
that if I move this back a little bit I
think it's
walking yeah she'll be okay see
better
so red is on um my name is Tracy McGraw
and I'm an attorney for the New
Hampshire Department of Labor thank you
for having me and I'm glad to ask uh
answer any questions that you have um to
go back to the question that was just
recently
discussed I believe representative stav
you asked what laws would apply
I can tell you in the reverse because
that's what we deal with a lot of in New
Hampshire a lot of people when they went
remote we're working for companies that
were outside of New Hampshire primarily
Massachusetts or Main and so then we
would have a remote worker who is now
working from home but still working for
that Massachusetts or Maine or other
state and the issue that came up was
workers compensation insurance
coverage and so New Hampshire has a
requirement for three 3A coverage New
Hampshire must be listed on the
information page of a workers comp
policy under 3A if it is not then it is
not a valid New Hampshire workers comp
policy so I can speak to it from that
perspective because I can speak on
behalf of any of the other surrounding
states but if a a Massachusetts for
example company had remote workers they
would then have to apply for and obtain
valid New Hampshire workers comp
coverage under 3A for those remote
workers ERS the information would be
provided to the insurance carrier as to
who they are what they did and payroll
gets factored into what the premiums may
be charged for that um when that remote
worker is back to working in the actual
office that's in Massachusetts in this
example then that New Hampshire coverage
may or may not be continue to be
required at all depends on whether or
not there's anyone left in New Hampshire
working for that
company so I hope that answered that
that question to the extent that I can
because again I can't speak on behalf of
Massachusetts or any of the other states
that's how New Hampshire would handle
it I have a follow-up question on that
so if that Massachusetts company has no
presence in New Hampshire except that a
worker lives here um what is the
mechanism by which the New Hampshire of
Department of Labor can
enforce in this case the provisions of
the workers comp law so what happens
when you have someone from out ofate an
employer from out of state that has no
connection theoretically to New
Hampshire it just has an employee that's
working remotely in New Hampshire that
employees payroll must be reported to
New Hampshire employment security and
then New Hampshire employment security
obviously detects that New Hampshire
payroll is being reported and the next
question is is is there New Hampshire
coverage New Hampshire employment
security would then generate what we
call a questionnaire that will be
delivered from the Department of Labor
goes out to the employer and asks is
this your correct Federal employer
identification number do you have
employees that are working in New
Hampshire and if so please provide us
with the insurance
information I'd say 80% of the time we
do not get responses and it ends up
coming to legal for petition and for
hearings at which time we do get
responses
um and it has happened a significant
amount of times because when the
pandemic hit a lot of people went remote
very quickly and a lot of businesses
were caught off guard as to what the
requirements were and assumed because if
anybody knows about workers compensation
insurance policies 3C on the information
page talks about all other states and
they assumed that if New Hampshire was
listed on all other states that that was
a valid New Hampshire policy which
obviously it is not so um in answer to
your question um New Hampshire
employment security in tandem with the
Department of Labor would be able to
keep track of that
information thank
you go with representative
Granger uh thank you I I didn't know I
was going to go into this uh section of
law today neither did
I um I I I I forgive you if you don't
have any uh sources with you but why is
it that New Hampshire's workers comp
requirements are different from other
states is is that listed in statute
actually it is listed in statute if you
look under Section 281a 5 and 7 that
talks about the workers comp
requirements and that New Hampshire must
be identified it doesn't specifically
come out and say it must be 3A on the
policy but interpretation of the statute
requires it to be listed as 3A
underneath the policy if you look at an
information page on a workers
compensation policy you'll see that
under 3C it actually lists I want to say
five maybe Six States where those States
actually provide workers compensation
for their employers so those particular
States can't be just globally
incorporated into a workers comp policy
there's a special process in order to
get in uh insurance for those States all
other states that do not have any
specific requirements like New Hampshire
has or those five to six states that I
just mentioned they can be listed under
3C on the policy are there any other
states that list or require 3A I know
there are I do not know what they
are thank you for having that number
just like in your head that's I
appreciate it it's it's a sick thing
what can I
say representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss
mcra um I have actually had two if I may
go ahead thank you sir I'm gonna would I
I'm gonna ask you to speculate because
we talked about workers comp and is it
likely that if people are working at
home they're less susceptible to
workplace injuries and there that's why
we haven't had uh what you might expect
for a normal range of complaints for a
large number of employees working at
home I can't speak to whether or not
they are less susceptible but the bottom
line is is if you're working in an
office and you're walking around the
office but you're working at home and
you're walking around at home it would
appear that you have the same risks
involved um you would go through if you
were trying to prove whether something
was a workers's compensation case for a
remote worker versus a workers's
compensation case for someone who's
actually working in the office you still
have to go through the same questions
and the same type of a hearing on
causality uh just because they're
working at home doesn't negate the
possibility of a workers's compensation
claim you still have have the repetitive
motion type injuries that can happen in
a regular workplace but think about it
from just this one example someone is
walking down a straight path there is no
defects in the um the flooring there's
no poles in the carpet there's no divots
there's nothing and this is at work they
trip and they fall that's probably going
to lean more towards a worker's CL
injury depending upon the other facts
that go with it if they're at home and
that's an issue
and they're walking down and there's no
defects
no that can be the same problem a lot of
it depends on the facts behind it so if
they're carrying something for work if
they're carrying a briefcase if they're
lifting their laptop if what they're
doing is a work-related activity
requiring them to not have their hands
free requiring them to um I I can't
think of of different possibilities but
handsfree seems to be the biggest issue
when you're just walking on a flat
surface
that can be a comp comp case at off the
office and it can be a workers's comp
case at home it really comes down to
facts okay my last my last question uh
on another related issue with remote
work um is uh a colleague on the
committee told me that he was working
for a company located in Massachusetts
which we know has Stellar laws regarding
uh unused vacation pay UNF 10 and that
person received his he had to contest it
but he did receive his unused vacation
pay would that be something that would
be uh addressed uh in our in remote work
typically I think state lines yeah I I
think it would have to depend on what
the employer feels is appropriate to put
into it but if it's a Massachusetts
company and the Massachusetts company
has
specific uh contractual agreements with
the employee yet yes we offer PTO yes we
pay out PTO whether it's a percentage or
or
whatever it can be done to make it
perfectly clear and to remove all uh
vagueness in any type of an agreement
have we had any of those issues come
across I can't answer that question yeah
I'm gonna add Maine to that list because
Maine also has this law that uh it
doesn't matter what the circumstances
were you get your vacation pay thank you
thank you is no uh any other questions
for Department of
Labor seeing none thank you and I oh yes
and pass your card around when um and I
still have one final card uh Gary abbit
is representing the associated general
contractors um is going to speak in
Bill thank you chairman for the record
my name's Gary Abbott I'm the executive
vice president of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire and I
apologize ahead of time because I'm
going to probably make this even more
confusing to you uh reading the bill I
first read the bill and said you
know employees and employers should
understand the terms and conditions but
then when focusing on this one line uh
the first thing that hit me was the end
of the sentence reference to all
applicable laws and regulations
now I'm an employer I I don't know how I
would write the terms and conditions
with all applicable
laws um I'm supposed to reference them
I'm I'm not so sure even with me being a
lobbyist don't know all of the the laws
the second part is
the are we are we forcing contracts here
with the terms and conditions I can tell
you as an
employer we have remote work and I don't
want to confuse things either I
represent the construction industry and
originally I thought we have nothing to
do with remote work but what is the
definition of remote work uh I hope it
doesn't turn into a construction crew
working in a different town is remote I
think you're trying to talk about
working from home but not everybody on
remote work works from home so I think
we need a definition of what remote work
is the the terms and conditions I can
tell you as an
employer we're going through the process
when covid hit my staff turned into
working from home that became a norm for
most offices uh there were no written
terms and conditions it was to try to
perform your work that you were going to
do in in office and I also talked about
the construction I I asked contractors
and they said oh Gary we have offices
that do all the payroll and all that
stuff we have employees that that work
remote so this bill does affect us but
what I was getting to is I think the
normal Pro progression for a company is
we're adopting position descriptions
with what the employee does for remote
and not remote when they can't be remote
it's much more detailed you know trying
to draft this this is a remote work
where I get hired by Amazon to answer
questions and I just stay home all the
time
but there are situations like for me as
an employer none of my employees whether
they're part-time or full-time stay home
all the time there's requirements to be
in the office with Team meetings with
different scenarios certain days you
have to be in the office well I want to
make that clear in their position
description I don't think we need a
state law plugged in to start describing
what I need to do to protect both the
the employee and myself of what the work
Arrangement is and that varies I mean
the remote work language I develop for
my part-time people and my full-time
staff is completely different regarding
remote work and it is a thing of today
but this seems to run down a path
where there's a lot of flexibility in
drafting those specific to a position
and the details of what the person does
does and this how it's drafted seems to
limit my flexibility as an employer
because those those arrangements change
they changed from back when it was covid
to today it's much different situation
and the employer needs to have that
availability to change things because
our business changed different times of
the year we do different things so it's
not a onesize make this language and
done so that's why we oppose it is that
this kind of sets up almost a state law
that says you got to do this and I think
it's a field day for attorneys in the
future my what I wrote was not good
enough or the terms were not clear
enough so we worry about the liability
from either side so I I there's a lot of
questions here it's a great oneliner but
I'm not so sure I understand what the
details and I can tell you coming here
today I never even thought about the
workers comp not even on my radar um my
employees don't live in other states so
that doesn't apply to my company
but there's a lot here when you say all
applicable laws which laws are we
talking about so I would end my
testimony there and just uh that's why
we oppose it I think there's either
clarification or other options should be
available to
employers thank you very much uh are
there questions for this
witness representative lir thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Abbott I
think you might be making a little
broader than it seems to be only because
I think what the bill was supposed to be
is just for remote workers at
home I mean you I know there's going to
be issues with I mean times when they go
to the office go to another job site
perhaps but I believe and
uh representative McKenzie can qu can uh
correct me but I think it means only for
remote when you're at
home or you know it might be at a
restaurant or something I guess if
you're doing you know taking your
computer with you but it's remote work
um I've been in construction for a long
time too I don't uh if I'm doing my work
on my house I don't call that remote
work because I'm doing it for myself but
if I'm working for somebody I'm just
bringing up I I I I think I get the
basis I think I think an easy thing for
me would to agree with would be
employers need to make sure that in some
method that they're um relaying those
those I mean I personally have done it
verbally uh the writing thing makes it
more harder for me to quickly do
something uh a person has a medical
issue and you want them to continue to
work uh I got to draft up a an agreement
uh when that person can't come back to
the office even though I want to keep
them employed I just I think we're on
the same page it should be described as
best they can and if you're trying to
get away from verbal
agreements uh I I just think there needs
more thank you are there other questions
for the
witness uh representative D
sylvestra well yes uh when when this uh
person is done I'd like to ask
representative McKenzie a question to
come back that's all right and in the
interest well we've gone beyond and
since we have the sponsor of the bill in
um that it may be appropriate to discuss
it during our work session too uh I'll
leave it up to you you can um but
representative kill you had a question
yes thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Abbott um I I I do sense that we are
sort of near very near agreement on on
the issue uh but it's the matter of uh
writing all the all the possible rsas
and sub references to this and that I we
that probably wasn't isn't really
required but uh would you say that uh
just adding subject to subject to
different conditions or changes uh this
schedule this this this is how we'll do
remote work would that be something that
would be reasonable to put in your
employee manual oh I think many
employers would put that that you know
this is the arrangement and subject to
change uh to deal with whatever changes
in your office may may be I agree with
that that that would be in there um but
where is the right place to put it and I
guess it just says in writing in work
Arrangement if you're just saying I can
put that in a job description or in an
office policy then I'm fine with that
but keep in mind th this is going to be
a big undertaking for a lot of
businesses that don't have it in those
policies that went through covid quickly
went into remote work and still have
it just a quick followup would you agree
Mr Abbott that a written agreement a
veral agreement is worth the paper it's
written
on uh I I guess I would agree with that
thank you sir are there further
questions and are you
okay okay um so that's all the cards
that I have so unless there's someone
else uh that wanted to speak I will
close the public hearing on this bill
and representative McKenzie if you could
hand up the blue sheet while you're
that and um while we're waiting at the
sponsor of the next
bill I informed the
chairman um that they are not going
they're going to ask us to itl this bill
and the reason is that the the same or
very similar language has been submitted
both in the house and in the Senate and
the sponsors want to concentrate on the
Senate version rather than duplicate the
work in both houses at the same
time
is y so
uh for the blue sheet on 10
17 there were no um people signed up so
there are no additional names for that
so uh with that the hearing on 107 is
closed and I will open the hearing on
10:23 and unless this somebody
sponsoring the bill is
here um I would ask if there's a
volunteer from the committee just to
you
hello I'm representative Linda D
sylvestro and representing the sponsor
of this bill representative a Davis I
wish to withdraw this bill from
committee thank you very
much um and so uh one I had two cards up
here
one also withdraw the card all
right all right so uh they're
and these probably don't need to go in
speak why don't you do that yourself
yes are there any other names on the
besides
you all
you so with that I will close uh the
hearing on House Bill
1023 and our next scheduled hearing is
at
11:15 so um
we will recess the committee until 11:15
and then pick up
again
y
for
so it being a little bit after 11:15
we'll get
started um and yes make sure you fill
out a pink card and get it to our
temporary clerk here um so we're now
picking up with House Bill
um representative kahill will is the
sponsor and will introduce his Bill
thank you Mr chair uh again
representative Michael Cahill
representing the Rockingham 10 the towns
of newfields and New Market um the topic
is familiar to members of the committee
we've been talking about this for a
little while now and as I've indicated
in this uh slightly updated sheet from
from last year it's an ongoing
situation uh you in
2023 of 250 wage claims
uh that went to a decision that went to
a hearing s 78% 78 or 31% involved this
issue as a factor not not necessarily
the only issue but it was it was part of
it and I and I've seen from you know my
reading of these decisions that the
employers sometimes have a policy
sometimes they don't and sometimes they
say uh it's a case-by casee basis which
you know is in Practical and
um but we've narrowed this with 117 8
we've narrowed it down to only two sit
circumstances where we would agree that
the employee has no control over this
this is not him
voluntarily uh leaving this is uh
there's a lay you're calling into the
breakroom and is a layoff today's your
last day or the company's been sold and
I may or may not have uh taken into
account that you had two weeks vacation
and you you know had requested it or you
had this coming to you and I may or may
not have included that with my
negotiations with the new owner and what
we're what we're trying to do here is
see that uh in both these instances the
employee does not lose what they've had
what they've earned and had little or no
opportunity to to make use of it um with
the company either either um certainly
if you're having difficulty thinking
about a layoff you're probably not
approving vacations you need everybody
all hands on deck uh when you want to
when you're thinking about selling the
company you want to appear productive
and you may not you may be withholding
uh vacation time but in any case even if
everything is going well someone's bound
to have some hours that they have earned
and this bill would ensure that they are
that they don't forfeit that through no
fault of their own um now I want to draw
your attention as was just happened with
me uh to something an improvement that
amendment uh credits credit to the team
this section
two uh for the purpose of this section
the terms earn time vacation or vacation
time and pay time off have the same Mee
and their value as wages should be paid
to the
employee um what we should have there is
pursuant to the employer's practice or
policy added to that phrase as it is for
this sick time and sick days but again
this the this would be pursuant to their
policy other than the instances Down
Below in uh in SEC sure that was Roman
two in section two where we talk about
the circumstances a layoff or the
company being sold uh in in
this in in those in those circumstances
then they the employee would be
compensated for their earned time uh
that's that's the wrinkle
there but I I would agree with uh the
gentleman behind me that
uh that adding that brief uh section A
Brief phrase to the end of uh Roman
section one Roman 2
uh would be clear and would avoid a
misunderstanding and there are enough if
you read those wage claims as I do there
are enough misunderstandings now we
don't need
more gladly take any
questions right thank you are there
questions for the
sponsor representative love could you
clarify that uh representative um you
know the uh pursuant of PR practice of
policies here the employer employers uh
could you clarify what we were talking
about yeah thank thank you
um
so what the my my aim here with the the
language pursuant to the employer policy
is used with the sick time or sick days
and in that sense I'm say what I'm
saying is uh we hope that our employees
don't get sick but the time is available
if they do but if they don't get sick
and they had good health I'm not
suggesting that that those hours be paid
out um but I could understand from the
point of view uh that uh that this could
be added um to the part above where
we're talking
about the vacation time earn time uh
pursuant to that would be U had this so
for the the same the same SE for the
purpose of this section the uh these
would not be paid out this would be
pursuant to the employer's practice or
policy but then that is
superseded in uh the new section below
where it's a layoff or the sale of the
company that would uh pardon the
expression
Trump
practice and if I may I'm going to
editorialize just a little bit more
again from I spent the weekend reading
the those 78 wage claims and while it's
not part of this bill uh I think I would
urge businesses to consider uh whether
you would have all your things all PTO
in one thing or sick time and earn time
just to have everything acrude because a
lot of the misunderstandings that I've
seen are when people say you have all
your hours January 1 your anniversary
date you have all your hours they're all
yours and then someone thinks I can take
them even if I work for the company for
a month or two and and you'll pay me all
of
that believe me I've seen it or you know
or when they when they're not clear on
this so I I really think a cruel where
you can say at you earn so many hours
per week that you work is simpler it's
understood it used to be the norm and
you you could avoid all these troubles
you had the option of course if someone
says well I've got this special event
coming and I don't have quite enough
time to to uh Advance them to so go
negative in the in the in on the payroll
and then um the other part of this is
right right now an employer who does
advance something to the employee has to
get it in writing that they agree to pay
it back or I'll take it from their final
paycheck uh one of the claims I read was
somebody who the employer loaned the
employee $1,000 it didn't say why but
then wanted to take it from their P
final paycheck and because he didn't
have the written
agreement that you know that so that's
that's another bill another time uh
maybe next year but for our purpose
today um I just think that this this uh
protects the workers in these rare
circumstances uh where it's no fault of
their own and I've demonstrated
previously that substantial sums of
money have been forfeited and uh in
those unique
circumstances uh with employers of 15 or
more which is a small again small number
of employers in the state we would like
to do
this thank you further questions for the
sponsor seeing none thank you very much
thank you I have a handful of cards here
uh first up I would ask Gary Abbott of
associate general contractors who has
signed up opposed to the
bill
thank you chairman uh labor committee
members again for the record my name is
Gary Abbott I'm the Executive Vice
President of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire uh I know
you all are aware we've had similar
bills in the past the association's
policy has been for me representing them
that they want their office policies to
dictate their benefit benefits of
vacation and sick time however it's
drafted for the company uh one of the
things that we looked at at this bill as
it it is different than previous bills
but it still starts to write policy and
I think that's what representative
kahill's talking about the thing that I
noticed in line 12 and 13 it didn't say
in accordance with the office policy
whether you had to give a a notice of
your leaving to be eligible for vacation
pay or whatever other conditions many
companies ask for a proper notification
or things that are contingent on getting
those uh vacation pay and other things
so it seems to divert away from what the
company policy outlines as either the
procedure to get it or who qualifies
because the company policy really is the
legal document that is used by the labor
department if there's a contest uh with
an employee saying I didn't get paid the
proper amount they go look at the
employer's policy how does it dictate
this still puts in certain things it
starts to put in some things that are
written into different company policies
that are different I mean it sets if
you're 15 or more you have to do these
certain things so that that's why we're
here opposed because it doesn't directly
say pursuant to the company policy uh it
it starts to impede on that and if you
were to make that change it would be
better but it still is a little bit of a
conflict for me when companies want to
use their policy um always a problem is
me sitting in the back of the room
reading the bill over and over before a
hearing and at first I thought I was
good with section two and then I read it
again because I represent construction
we have layoffs every year in
construction and the opening of line 18
starts with this section shall apply as
a result of a layoff well many of the
seasonal companies I represent have
layoffs they already have the procedures
that they follow with the unemployment
office they know what meets the law I
think the intent and you would have to
ask the sponsor is after that sentence
in those unusual cases in which a
business is sold or goes out of business
I would concur after that but not the
layoff as the trigger um I started to
try to come up with terms permanent
layoff you know the company closing I
think that's what section two is trying
to get at which I don't have any issues
with because those are where a
transaction's happening and I think you
want to protect the employee because
they're not able to do what the company
policy says because it's switching to a
new company so I'm I'm not objecting to
that notion but I don't want to affect
what companies have as their current
policy and I I just have trouble with
that opening line and just blanket
statement uh because there may be
companies that carry some of the
benefits into the next season as part of
encouragement to get them to come back
to work for them so I don't want to ruin
those things by putting in law that you
have to do certain steps that you may
not have to now I'm not an expert at
every layoff and what the rules and
conditions are but that's why we're in
opposition I think if it was tailored
just to uh where it starts on line 19 if
it's a result of a change in company
that very narrow uh I think we've said
this even in previous hearings uh in
previous years that if it was to that
particular item we understand and then
would be able to support the bill for
those rare instances that that happens
but with that we have some difficulty
because it is moving away from the
company policy being the the document
that the Labor Department goes with and
now inserting some things that are
mandatory into my policy with that I'd
end my testimony and uh take any
questions you may have thank you very
much are there questions for this
witness representative
avalani thank you Mr chairman good to
see you again Mr Abbott um you you've
touched on a couple things um i' I'd
like to go back to uh sections 12 to
15 um if a company only has one
PTO so they acrew at a certain thing is
this trying to redefine what earn time
vacation vacation time and pay time off
is and making it separate from sick time
and sick days it may be but the real
question here is if that's described in
my office policies or a company's
policies of how it is why do we need
this section completely I guess it's
the thank you follow Mr chairman follow
um and I also agree with you under on
line 18 that determination to result of
layoff um you represent asphalt
companies correct across the board I
mean all kinds y um you guys do do use
the layoff policy through the year for
certain times of the year if it's a
rainy season and you guys aren't say
Paving till later it's usually winter
and Paving you can't pave when it's uh
you know below right if you have that if
you automatically pay out all of their
vacation time all of their PTO time all
of their time that's going to affect
their ability to to collect um
unemployment insurance it's going to
delay that process even longer well and
and I guess that's where I know going
back to my office with those employers
that may be a problem as I sat here and
read it I oh we're getting into an area
where I'm not so sure I know all of the
regs but I don't want to affect it if
it's possible not to affect those
employers right and my last followup Mr
chairman followup question question
question um would it also affect the
unemployment insurance having a large
sum paid out before being laid off would
it increase the cost of the business
saying okay well he's got six weeks
vacations we get to pay him now he has a
delay in his unemployment it's it's
twofold I I'm not really sure okay I'm
not really sure what the impact would be
um I just know that uh contractors like
any other are trying to keep their
employees as long as they can extra work
you know so um snowplow if they can put
the time in they try to work something
out so I think times have changed that
uh um you know employers try to do as
much as they can but for those that have
to get laid off I think I don't want to
affect
those thank you thank you Mr thank you
Mr chairman further
stuff thank you for taking my question
Mr Abbott um in the event of an
unexpected closure or layoff how would
an individual be able to provide
notification that they wanted to take
their paid or sick leave to the employer
if um they were unaware that the B
business would be closing moving or that
they were being laid off I I think the
point you're making is the one that I
would say I agree with uh if you were to
leave the further point where there was
uh a closure a sale uh some of that
effect that the employees did not have
their opportunity to take and meet the
company policy uh that would be a
variable that I would agree with that's
in that section two if you get rid of
just normal layoffs and describe those
situations where your absolutely correct
employee did not get the opportunity to
request the vacation so therefore they
shouldn't be denied it so I'm in
agreement with that position I'm trying
not to affect all the good business
businesses that are going currently and
operating successfully thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you next I would ask David juv of the
Bia to speak um he signed up for three
bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee again for the record my name
my name is Dave ju I'm senior vice
president for public policy at the
business and industry Association um we
are neutral on the bill and I'd like to
explain why because I know there will be
some people on the committee who might
be surprised to hear
that
um the primary reason is that this issue
of dealing with
employees that representative stab so
eloquently asked about those individuals
that that that have a crude time they
may have been planning to take vacation
over the summer who knows but through no
fault of their own were um denied the
opportunity to do that that there should
be some
recognition the reason we're neutral on
this is because I'm the one who
suggested that idea to representative K
Hill as a starting point for this bill
and I felt it would be bad form to have
suggested that but then oppose
it um I think that the number of
employers that would be impacted by this
is very small it's uh 15 or more
employees and it's the bills written um
only would affect those that that where
the business is being sold and and those
acred time are not passed on to the new
employer or there is a uh layoff and the
uh individual had no notice of that
happening I I think there does need to
be some tightening up uh I think uh Gary
Abbott made some good points I don't
know what the solution is um I think it
might be worthwhile having um a
discussion with the Department of
Employment Security to get their
thoughts on it um I mean one option
would be to just eliminate that
provision entirely but if there's some
way of
capturing those individuals who are who
are subject to a layoff that is not part
of a seasonal work
agreement then I think it should be
explored the reason we're not supporting
the bill is that there are um issues
again uh Gary Abbott was very eloquent
in in stating these
um I believe most employers it's in
their best interest to have their
vacation and sick time policies uh
clearly articulated and written down as
a part of the employee um employee
manual if they
don't all kinds of uh confusion and and
bad things can occur so I would hope
that most employers do this whether the
state needs to be dictating to employers
that they do this is is perhaps another
question um we've already talked about
the uh section having that uh added the
um
pursuant to the employer's practice or
policy I I do actually think that's
important to have that added um
representative love was asking I think
for examples of of if you don't have
that where confusion could be created
and I'll give you an example the company
I work for has paid vacation time um
it's a use it or lose it type of
arrangement meaning if I don't use the
amount of paid time that I have accured
by the end of the year I lose it and we
start fresh on January 1st by not
including that language in here it
leaves some confusion about whether
employees are entitled to be compensated
for that time or not so I think it is a
good idea to add that the other um
problem that will be
created um I think it is limited but it
will be a problem for some employers is
those that don't articulate or stipulate
the difference between vacation time and
sick time some just have a personal time
off policy and you use it if you're not
feeling well you use it if your um uh
child is not feeling well you use it if
you're going on
vacation
and it's going to be confusing for those
companies to understand how to implement
this um bill again I would point to you
we're talking about a relatively small
number number of employers here but they
do exist another example with some
employers that is becoming
increasingly um common especially in
tech jobs is to not have any uh vacation
or sick time at all that is acred the
it's up to the individual employee to to
use their work time uh wisely and see
benefit and the employer understands
that from time to time they're going to
be taking time off if they're sick or
vacation time uh but it's not something
that is tracked relatively small number
of employers but but they do exist so
because because there are these issues
uh representing employers that that are
real we couldn't really support this
bill either we thought that the um
sponsor was making a good faith effort
to try and do what is fair for a for a
small number of
employees uh those that have acred time
and then never had the opportunity to
use it because of an adverse um experi
an adverse situation with their employer
happy to don't know if I kept my three
minutes I might not have but I'm happy
to answer any questions thank you very
questions presentative
Avalon thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Jupe for taking my questions um the
same questions I gave Mr Abbott U it
looked section two looks they're
redefining earn time PTO into wages due
when leaving sick time as a outlier uh
similar the answer is yes um again I'm
not sure section one is necessary to do
what the sponsor really wants to do with
this bill um I think it creates as many
problems as is possibly situations it's
trying to to correct but but the answer
to your question is yes some employers
are not either not going to understand
how to do that or it conflicts with what
is um so the we know section one is an
issue um through
your Bia how many employers do you have
that are above 15 employees at this
would fact it it's not 100 it's not 100%
we have many surprising to some we have
a number of small uh business businesses
um that would have less than 15
employees off the top of my head and
this is a bit of a guess I would say
it's possibly 20% of our membership so
you follow so it's mostly smaller micro
businesses that would not be affected by
this yeah I I don't know that that uh
businesses of 14 employees or less would
be impacted by it at all thank
svin I'm trying to address actually what
uh Mr Abbott U mentioned as you did as
well if um and Mr Abbott ought to
listen he's not going to
um dealing with section two again um in
addressing the uh the layoff issue if
the um word unanticipated was inserted
before layoff would that uh address the
problem I uh excellent question possibly
an excellent suggestion um I think it
would help but again I think it would
benefit hearing from Employment Security
exp if if the committee wants feels like
there's a a germ of a good idea here but
we want to be careful of unintended
consequences might be worth getting
their impact explaining to them what the
conflict is and getting their
suggestions on how best to move forward
thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony um the next card I have and if
I uh mispronounce this I apologize in
advance Katherine heck who is
representing nhma and is speaking in
minute good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Katherine heck and I
represent the New Hampshire municipal
Association the 234 cities and towns in
New Hampshire and I will preface by
saying the next person to testify um
will have a much more detailed testimony
and we don't want to waste your time or
be redundant in any way my um I serve in
the role of the government Finance
adviser so I help cities and towns with
all types of Finance questions and
Taxation and my testimony while we
believe that this already exists in law
and these protections already exist in
current law as they're written I did
want to draw your attention to the
fiscal note um well we had
indeterminable increase in expenditures
at the local level um the methodology
would be the same as the states so this
bill if passed as written um and I do
understand there's some discussion
around amendments and we certainly
appreciate that the sponsor has um
brought back a different version of this
bill to address some of our concerns but
when we set our budgets our local tax
taxpayers the budget itself is what
you're taxed on not what you spend but
what the approved budget is and we would
have to budget to maximum exposure based
on on this so that is passing that along
to the taxpayer currently our practice
and again um Mr Iran will will testify
to how the budget process works in his
community so he can be more specific but
you you look at your highest liabilities
and that's the budget you set set
forward so we are concerned that not
only is this already
codified in law these protections for
our employees but that we would have to
be increasing our budget just as the
state would and carry that on in order
to be in comp full compliance for
basically um our what if situations um
and of course if it's not used then we
wouldn't have that impact it would go
into fund balance and could be returned
to the taxpayers at a later date but
again it would affect that local tax
bill um again I won't waste any of your
time again I will let Mr Irv talk about
his points um but I'll certainly
entertain any questions thank you very
much are there questions for this
witness represent Granger uh thank you
um you you say that the protections are
already in law do you know where um yes
um and again Mr Irvine will hand you out
written testimony that will show under
RSA 27535 a
27543 Roman it's all going to be in his
written testimony he'll have a copy for
you so I I won't time thank you any
further
questions all right thank you very much
thank you for your time and next I will
call Neil Irvine who is representing the
town of Northwood speaking in opposition
to the bill and has brought written
testimony for
along honorable chairman members of the
committee
again for the record my name is Neil
Irvin Town Administrator for the town of
Northwood I appreciate the opportunity
today please accept this testimony in
opposition to House Bill 1178 which we
would Doge this committee to find his
inexpedient to
legislate this bill ignores the reality
that every employer has the right and
ability to craft a benefits package that
meets the needs of the employer the
employees and their customers current
legislation requires an employer to
adhere to their policies and procedures
as they relate to that benefits package
and provides a mechanism through the
Department of Labor for an employee to
seek redress when an employer violates
the terms of
employment there is nothing in this bill
that provides protections that do not
already exist in statute thereby
rendering this legislation redundant
specifically new section 27
535a Roman numeral 1 a States inform
employees in writing of any policy
regarding acral or use of unused earn
time and any limits on acrel or use the
requirement to notify employees already
exists in
27549 Roman numeral 3 which states make
available in writing or through a posted
notice Employment Practices and policies
with regard to vacation pay pay sick
leave and other fringe
benefits new section
27535 a Roman numeral 1C provide
employees with an accountant of earned
time used and unused time remaining this
requirement to maintain such good
records quoted from labor administrative
rules
80303 section F4 and make available for
the enforcement of chapter 275
protective legislation is articulated in
27549 Roman numeral
6 new section
27543 Roman numeral 5 a States shall be
paid for unused earn time no later than
the next regular pay period is redundant
language as RSA
27544 Roman numerals 1 and two
provide excuse me protections for
employees who separate before a regular
payday regardless of who initiates the
separation new section
27543 Roman numeral
5A if the termination is the result of a
change of business ownership the prior
employer shall upon completion of the
transfer of ownership pay the employees
unused earn time wages or transfer the
employees unused earn time to the new
employer this protection is provided for
in labor administrative rule
80303 C every employer shall inform his
or her employees in writing of any
change to such employees rate of play
salary or Employment Practices or
policies as refer to in labor
80303 A and B prior to the effective
date of such change and labor rule 80303
D which states any vacation pay holiday
pay sick pay both bonus pay personal day
pay employee expenses and all other
fringe benefits earned acred or vested
prior to any change shall not lapse due
to the change we would also bring to the
committee's attention that in a very
competitive employment Market employers
have amended their benefit packages to
become an employer of choice many have
abandoned an acrw system verification
and sick leave nor they do they
differentiate between the various types
of time away from work simply referring
to as paid time off HB 1178 does not
make any allowance for these practices
taking a one-size fits-all approach we
would respectfully submit the HB 1178 is
not a solution in search of a problem
but rather a solution to a problem that
has already been resolved thank you for
your consideration of my testimony we
again urge the committee to find HP 1178
and expedient to legislate thank thank
you very much are there questions for
this
we representative
alalani thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Irvine for taking the question
what the what policy does the uh town of
Northwood do for uh paytime off so we
have currently an acrew
system and upon
separation uh you are paid for your
and for budgeting purposes we have an
Expendable trust fund um currently we
have a total exposure in the region of
$85 to
90,000 uh the Expendable trust fund is
funded at approximately 20% of that
exposure um as Miss HEC um previously
alluded to we would have to look at
increasing the Expendable trust fund to
100% exposure and the only way to
achieve that is to go to the property
monies thank you any other questions
representative
stop thank you for taking my question
mrvine um one of the things that we're
looking at um is protecting people who
might show up for work one day and find
a sign on the door saying that the
business is closed or get get called
into the cafeteria and learn that the U
business has been sold
um can you think of uh some kind of a an
an an analogous situation that would
happen in a municipal government that
you know someone would show up for work
and find that the town of Northwood is
closed for business and or has been sold
to um
[Laughter]
Massachusetts um certainly there there
have been instances um not locally but
there have been instances in the
municipal world where towns have gone
bankrupt um and so yes there there could
be the
potential um for someone to show up at
work um if you had a and this is purely
hypothetical but if you had multiple
years of default budgets where your
operating budget did not keep up with
inflation then is you could potentially
get to a situation where the town has to
look at cutting services and so instead
of having four or five plow drivers you
decide we can only afford to have
two um so there are extreme
circumstances um where that would happen
but as I I pointed out
in that world in the private sector of a
business closing unexpectedly or
transferring ownership the protections
already exist that say the employees
acrw time shall not go away they have
that right and they have the the
mechanism through the Department of
Labor um to seek
redress and as previously um articulated
by previous speakers the first thing the
department l is going to do is look at
the policies and procedures under which
the employee was hired and they will
always defer and give the benefit of the
doubt to the
employee in every instance where the
Department of Labor has come in and
looked at a wage concern they will
always give the benefit of doubt if
there is any confusion in what is being
articulated in those policies and
procedures to the
employee
any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony my pleasure
thank you gentlemen ladies I have one
last card for this bill uh Bruce berky
representing NF I forget what that IB
yes I'm sorry um and is signed up in
opposition to the bill I apologize for
the late card Mr chairman I arrived a
little late and glad to be before your
committee again for the record my name
is Bruce berky and I am the state
director for the national Federation of
Independent Business or
nfib and you've heard some very good
testimony here this morning uh relative
to HB
1178 and I just wanted I won't repeat it
it's it it was that good um but I I
guess one question and then uh a
statement uh and maybe not even a
question but online for it talks about
an employer that employs 15 or more
employees uh one of the questions I
guess I would have would be is that 15
people or 15 FTE full full-time
employees and so you know you could have
25 employees that would be the
equivalent of 15 full-time employees and
so I think that that would be um needed
to be further defined uh with respect to
that number and representing the over
1,400 small businesses in New Hampshire
that are members of nfib across the
state um we would recommend that you
increase that number from 15 to 50 um
making it consistent with some other
laws that are on the
books um if if this bill were to go
forward but we do not recommend that the
bill go forward we're concerned about
the Mandate that's built into the into
the bill um basically telling employers
how to manage their business how to
manage their relationship with their
employees and we think that that should
remain with the employer and the
employee and not be driven by the state
of New Hampshire so with that Mr
chairman I'll conclude my remarks and
happy to try and address any questions
questions I don't see any so thank you
again thank you and that is the last
card that I had if anybody was was
planning to speak and didn't fill out a
card please pass one up and
rep I it's a do not on security y okay
um so I had a request if uh the do could
um come up to answer a
question and we yes we sent the sheet
back out there in case we had people
walking in so we'll have to pass it back
you okay just to reintroduce myself on
this bill my name is Tracy mcra and I am
here on behalf of the Department of
Labor as one of their
attorneys and I believe we have a
question
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you
again Mr McGrath um the gentleman from
Northwood turned
in some very nice testimony um spe
specifically referencing lab
03.03
um you usually to get into your rules
but could we get a list of your
rules uh absolutely you're asking for a
coffee just to clarify as opposed to me
reciting the rules today I would I would
think that would be all of us would like
that but if you would like to um expound
on 8303 in the 80303 80303 if give me
one second I'm going to go pull my cell
phone which I have it pulled up on okay
perfect
if the committee would just grant me
just a minute or two because I was
Indulgence
and I wrote down the reference as 80303
C
correct okay and
D he cites both um C and D in his
testimony I have them pulled
up um what did you have a specific
question representative
avalani yes is is this bill already in
8303 keeping in mind that the labor
rules are there to fill in some
explanations fill in some of the blanks
but they are not
statutory um we we do not if if there is
a statutory provision that contradicts a
labor rule the statute obviously
prevails so these were put in place to
help explain that which is not maybe
perfectly clear within the statute but
has to be altered if the statute changes
so I just want to make that point
clear um so in C we have
um this is a notification that goes to
employees with resp effect to change in
pay rates that goes underneath the
notification statute and they are
required to provide those notifications
these are things that are determined
also during inspections that are done
wage and hour inspections as to whether
or not proper notifications have been
made to the employees notifications are
supposed to be in writing and they tend
to come up as pay stub changes or a
document that specifically states that
John Smith is now having his pay of $15
increase to $115.50 effective on such
and such a date and signed by the
employer and possibly the employee so
that is covered on that
aspect um and it has to be done prior to
the date of the change it can't be done
two weeks after the change of pay is is
in place um D talks about vacation
holiday pay sick pay bonus pay personal
day pay employee expenses and all other
French benefits earned acred or vested
prior to any change or lapse due to the
change the primary focus on all of this
is
notification this is just
notifying it would be a notification in
writing if there is a change to a policy
of any one of those types of
benefits um also wanted to point out too
and I'm I'm sorry if I'm going off topic
for just a second uh but there is a
definition under uh section 275 as far
as what an employee is so so I know that
that will help take care of that aspect
of it if the committee takes a look at
the definition section under
275 um there is a definition of employee
and it includes everybody not just
part-time not just full-time so I know
that was a concern with the last speaker
that was up here
um so I think that that covers what C
and D will do and these are
notifications that must be done in
writing and I believe these are Under
27549 thank you follow Mr chairman
follow um there's also notifications for
layoffs as
well there are not there are
notifications for layoffs there's uh
there's of course the official
notifications for layoffs which is under
the warrn statute which uh believe under
ours is
two70 okay I got we have it we have it
section f um so there is a state warn
statute there's also a federal warrant
statute that has to be complied with
there are numbers that have to be met in
order for a an actual formal warant
notice to be triggered and that is the
workers basically um retraining act um
sometimes does not apply we only apply
it obviously to New Hampshire companies
if they involve New Hampshire workers we
have to look at at that remote comes
into play as well uh as far as layoffs
are concerned those fit under Mass
layoffs Department of New Hampshire or
New Hampshire employment security has a
division that works with that we also
get notifications because by Statute
under the war act um the notifications
are required to go to various agencies
including
hours so yes there has to be
notifications made but if it doesn't
trigger the warn act it may not trigger
the same amount of time for
notifications the warn act requires that
notifications be made to the employees
at least 60 days prior to the layoff is
supposed to take place if if it's not a
triggered warn act
layoff that may not be the
same final followup what is that number
for the for the warrant act to come
in oh you're talking about as far as
number of employees it depends on
whether it's a plant lay off it depends
on if it's Federal and also for state
and I would not want to speak out but I
would I will gladly send a copy of the
warrn act and highlight the specific
sections that factor in whether or not
it's 25% of the Workforce whether or not
it's 100 employees versus 150 employees
there are a lot of numbers that are
factored in and I would be more than
happy to produce a copy of the warrant
act with highlighted sections in there
that would factor in uh exactly what the
requirements are to meet the trigger for
the warn act thank you thank you Mr
chairman I have a followup um when you
were discussing 80303 D and you were
saying that this
the purpose of this law or this rule has
to do with notification and I want to
clarify um the implication at least in
this written testimony I'll go to a
specific situation that we've talked
about in previous years so you have a a
company where um the policy is that
vacation is acre and is paid unused time
is paid out that's the company policy
and then that company is sold acquired
by another company who does not have
that
policy and um the way this is in here
with it's underlined the shall not lapse
due to the change the implication is by
this rule that the change in ownership
cannot change the
policy that the employee had acred that
time under that's the way I read the
you any further questions for the
Labor seeing none thank you very much
for stepping up for us and that was the
final card that I
had um and normally we don't bring
people back up is if this is something
that can't wait until we discuss the
bill in committee um
I
want
okay Mr chairman I do appreciate your
kind Indulgence uh and I regret I was
outside the room for the past two uh
speakers but I do want to say that you
know what uh M mcgr just said about
803 uh I have provided you know the
committee with prior examples where the
com the purchasing company did not uh
roll over they did not accept rollover
hours from the people who were laid off
at when the company was sold and the
previous owner did not pay them and
these people uh lost hundreds of dollars
because their
acrude vacation hours just
disappeared and that that is why I keep
on bringing this bill to you so that we
can stop that from happening in the
future um so it it doesn't if you may
read that way but that's not that's not
what happens in the hearings and and
that's that's something that I the uh
the option I believe the language of my
bill said the hours would be carried
over to the new employer or paid uh by
the Le departing owner which is what I
think many people would expect to happen
in that situation but because we allow
people to uh say are we don't pay it up
we don't pay the hours regardless of the
circumstances that
continues
um Mr Abbott's issue with lay with
layoff the dep the uh employment
security has an 11we threshold that if
if you're intended to go back you can go
collect unemployment which does affect
the UI balance and you can do so without
looking for work because you intend to
go back the employer intends to bring
you back uh but I believe after 11 weeks
that may not that may not continue or
perhaps it could be extended so this is
something I had looked at at a a prior
year about including similar language
that 11 weeks or we had to find a way to
describe it as as a temporary lay P off
uh not not permanent and in that case
the employee would be paid their
vacation hour because they don't they
don't anticipate coming
back and as we know that se these
seasonal or employers are are there are
are some number of them but there are a
great many in the state that do not work
seasonally that a job is a year round
job and when a layoff happens it's a
layoff and they're not coming
back again thank you for your
Indulgence thank you for the additional
information so before I close the
hearing I have the blue sheet for this
bill there were uh two signin that did
people who did not testify both signed
in opposed to the bill and with that I
will close the hearing on um
hb178 we have our next hearing scheduled
uh so we'll see everyone back atone
thank
you
for
all right it's a little bit after 1 o'cl
and uh so let's get started again and
first up I'd like
sponsor this is uh I am opening the
hearing on HB
and just for everyone's information we
heard from will he's on his way should
be here soon but he uh wasn't going to
be in time to start the hearing so asked
him
here
just
whenever you're
ready thank you Mr chairman um for the
record my name is uh Kathy stabb I am
representative representative from
Hillsboro 25 and I'm here to present um
HB
1322 um which I am the prime sponsor of
which is a bill to raise the minimum
wage um I don't know if I can be brief
but I will try to be
succinct um this bill raises the minimum
wage in increments until it reaches
$17 and it's um based on the federal
raise the wage bill
um wages um I have a um a cheat sheet
here and in the blue section it shows
how this bill will work um it is a very
conservative bill um in September of
2024 the minimum wage will go to $99.50
an hour from
$725 a year from now it'll be 11 it'll
go to 1250
14550 and then 17 in
2029 um
and that is very conservative um
currently um the um average starting
wage in the state of New Hampshire is
already over $15 an hour so this is not
going to have a huge impact on
businesses because most of them are
already paying more than
um than $15 an hour um starting out um
so why do we need this bill um well the
average medium wage in the state is
$24.10 that means half of the workers in
the state make less and the economic
policy Institute indicates that 18% of
1,2 one
124,000 um people in the state are
making less than $17 an hour and the MIT
minimum wage the MIT living wage
calculator estimates that a single
person need
$17.23 to live a decent life in the
state of New
Hampshire furthermore a third of U
Granite Staters reported to the United
States census um that um they're having
a difficult time paying their
bills um we have not raised our minimum
wage in the state since
2009 um in
2009 um a um a two-bedroom apartment
rented for uh $1,050
most recently um the New Hampshire
housing um indicated that a two-bedroom
apartment in the state of New Hampshire
$1,764 so in order for people to keep a
roof over their head and food on the
table and be able to uh get to work and
um God raise a family they they need
more uh money than they did in 2009 the
second reason that we need this bill is
that um every state in New England has a
much higher minimum wage um the green
section on
your um on your cheat sheet um shows
what the minimum wage is in other states
um the lowest minimum wage in New
Hampshire is um
$13.67 and that's in Vermont and right
now they have a bill going through their
their legislature that's going to raise
it to
$19 um Massachusetts is the only other
state in New England that didn't raise
their minimum wage this year um they're
at 15 but there's currently a bill going
through their um uh House of
Representatives um that will raise the
minimum wage to uh $20 an hour
so um so th those are those
are I think that puts us at a
disadvantage um one of the issues that
we have I you also included on here what
the unemployment rate is in other states
and you can see they're all fairly low
some economists think that anything
under three indicates a a a critical
labor shortage and I think we're all
aware that we do have a labor shortage
in the state of New Hampshire I was just
at a New Hampshire Phil fiscal policy
Institute presentation where they said
that for every three job openings
there's one person in New Hampshire
that's looking for work so we don't have
enough people to fill all of the jobs
that we have in the state and
that's you know if we don't raise the
minimum wage it's going to be harder for
us to attract workers we've already seen
a decline in our Workforce of around
16,990 workers and the um critical to
that is that the there has been a
significant decline um in among workers
ages 20 to 29 and those are people who
are just starting out in their careers
not mid career where you you know
starting wage would be 30 40 um dollars
an hour so those people um are not going
to be working in New Hampshire they're
going to cross the border where they're
guaranteed a much higher
wage and um so this low unemployment
rate has certainly um impacted the
workforce and that it has this worker
shortage has um given workers leverage
to to raise wages and that's good for
them but I think in the long
term the limiting factor for the State
of New Hampshire to um grow our economy
is going to be the number of workers
that we have so um I think we one thing
we can do um as an institution is raise
the minimum wage show the world that New
Hampshire values its workers and that
people are welcome to come here and that
we will assure that they have a good
quality of life in exchange for their
hard work
um thank
you thank you very much and um just
right now we you are prepared to take
over the clerk duy
so we can just hand everything
over and thank you for your testimony
are there questions for the sponsor of
this
bill representative bushard um would you
believe that when I was canvasing to get
reelected um last term that I had
constituents in Manchester who are
working two to three jobs to put food on
their table and pay their
rent yes I I believe that um I also ran
into the same thing when I was um when I
was out canvasing this last time um and
also the um data um supports that
because why while the number of people
in the workforce has declined the number
of jobs has actually increased in the
state so that means that there are
people that are working more than one
job at a significant level and that I
McKenzie
uh yeah yes um this bill would increase
the tipped wage to 50% of the of the
minimum wage but um so that it would be
more competitive with other states you
can see on the um list of um wages for
other states that the tipped wage in
Maine is $7 an hour and in New Hampshire
it's
$327 an hour uh one of the questions
that we're frequently asked um is how
many people are actually working for
$725 an hour I I think that's the wrong
question to be asking because um
$725 is kind of irrelevant right now
what we should be asking is how much
money do people living in New Hampshire
need to make in order to have a decent
quality of life um however um the um
Bureau of Labor Statistics reports that
there are about 4,000 people who make
less than $25 an hour and that um and
they they suspect that um that those may
be we we suspect that that that may be
um tipped wage workers who make
$327 an hour however um an important
consideration to that is that if some
someone goes into work and um they uh
are a waitress or they are working in
one of those um chain hair salons and
and they go in to work and they're there
for a few hours and nobody comes in then
their employer is only um required to
pay them
$7.25 an hour for the the amount of time
that they're there before they're sent
home and you know what worse um they can
they can
um they can average so if I'm a waitress
and I go into work and I have a really
good day on Monday and then Tuesday I go
into work and I spend two hours filling
salt shakers or cleaning the bathroom or
um rolling silverware um and then they
send me home for those two hours if they
average I'm only getting paid
$327 an hour and I think that that um
may be a contributing factor to the fact
that many um restaurant have are having
a difficult time finding uh
workers so thank you for the question
any further
questions uh does anybody have a first
question no so representative buard you
recognized for thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you for taking my question now to
what extent might a higher minimum wage
decrease to Reliance on low-wage workers
on government assistant
programs well you know very famous thank
you for the question very famously
Walmart one of the first thing they do
when they um hire new employees is to
tell them how to apply for food stamps
um because while their profits are
growing um they're not they're not
paying their workers a living wage I
mean I I
um I obviously you know if people are
making more money they're the thing
about raising wages for the lowest um uh
paid workers is that they spend every
cent of that money they're not going to
be buying stocks uh they're not going to
be um you know investing in
uh uh putting it in the bank they're
going to be spending it they're going to
be spending it on food they're going to
be spending it on rent it's going to go
they're going to be buying gas it's
going to go directly back into the
economy which will support small
businesses so for for every dollar that
you give a a low-wage worker it can be
multiplied multiple times and yes it
will um reduce the Reliance on things
like um food banks um food stamps and uh
other um forms of
um government
um uh subsidies that U low low-wage
workers have to rely on in order to
profits thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you very
much um next up I have Olivia Lennox
representing herself and is going to
speak two to three minutes in support of
the
bill I am okay hi everyone thanks for
having me um my name is Olivia I'm 27
years old and I own a small business in
Manchester New Hampshire we are a
restaurant and Cafe so this would be the
service
industry um I have been in the industry
since I was 15 years old my first job
was in Manchester at another small
business and um since 2019 I've owned
small businesses in New Hampshire as
well as in Oregon I lived there for a
little
while
um it's hard to know exactly what to say
because to me it seems
obvious that
$7.25 is just not a livable wage um and
going off of some of the numbers that
you heard at the last testimony um you
know it's calculated this year 2024 that
a living wage for an individual in New
$17.23 um it was also calculated that
the poverty wage for an individual in
New Hampshire is $6
53 so I think we're just a little bit
too close to that at this number um this
bill and its outcome affect folks who
work for an hourly rate many of them are
employed at local businesses such as my
own small businesses represent Community
because we interact with Community every
day and customers support my local
business because they know that they are
stimulating their local economy
and it is our job as business owners to
bridge that gap for them and there are
few ways that we can do that you know we
can Source from local vendors whenever
possible we can get involved in our
community but we can also pay our
employees who are from our community a
livable wage right and so just to give
you some examples of my numbers um it's
funny because all of my employees are
tipped because they are in the
restaurant industry so looking at this
tipped wage which I do understand
because I was a waitress in New
Hampshire for a long time so just to
touch on the tipped wage a little bit um
the
$327 so as a business owner right now I
could choose to pay my employees
$327 an hour and so long as within that
hour they make that extra three or $4 in
tips to bring them up to that
$725 that's all I'm responsible for
$327 and so I did that for a long time
actually as a as a waitress luckily you
know this was an established restaurant
so I was making you know more than $4 an
hour in tips maybe 25 you know so that
was helpful um however still if I didn't
have a table right I was still sweeping
I was still wiping down tables wiping
down cleaning the bathroom um wiping
down the salt and pepper shakers doing
doing tasks and leaving with
$7.25 that did happen to me my employees
right now start at $15 an hour and that
was my choice I opened in 2022 and I
knew I was in uh I had the opportunity
to make that decision so that I could
build my business around the structure
of paying my employees $15 an hour
starting even though I really didn't
have to like I didn't you know so while
yeah sure I I feel that when I when I do
payroll every week at the same time it's
my responsibility to deal with that in
my own way and I'm happy to do it
because my employees are excited to work
there I teach them things they learn
things from me we work as a team and
they have the ability to feed their kids
and to have you know fun outside of work
and to come to work and not to live to
work but to work to live and it's
fulfilling for them and that brings me a
lot of joy and I think that this is long
overdue honestly um the I have this
percentage that I work off of when it
comes to net sales versus labor on the
low end of net sales versus labor is 25%
and on the high end is 35% that's how I
can tell at any given time if I'm you
know not as busy as I should be for the
amount of employees that I have on
working at $15 an hour and last year I
was at
29% that's with paying them between $5
and $18 an hour that's really not bad
I'm I'm doing fine so I'm I'm just here
to say that um you know it's it's just
long overdue work is work you know
whether they're getting paid hourly or
salary if they're in the industry
they're working hard they go home and
their feet hurt you know and I just had
a um a meeting with the psychologist
actually um that's personal but he
mentioned that he could never do what I
do because it involves working with the
general public and that's a biggest fear
of his and he has a salary he went to
school you know he he's a psychologist
but he could never do what it is that I
do in the industry work is work and
people deserve to get paid you know I my
employees who make $15 an hour plus tips
they end up making around $26 an hour on
a good week with those tips um that is
pretty good I mean for an industry job
but they again they're working 30 35 to
40 hours a week they they deserve to
make that and so yeah I'm I'm all for it
and I think we should really think about
it and I really do believe that small
businesses they can they can handle this
at this point in time um you can work at
Dunkin' donuts for $15 an hour that's
why I started at 15 because I wanted
that's the industry as well you know I
mean granted Dunkin Donuts is a large
business but there are ways that small
businesses can work around this you know
like and I just don't think that
allowing them to continue to pay people
$725 is helping in the long
run that's all thank you for your
testimony are there questions for this
witness representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question would you say
that then then with your employees you
are paying them to work and the
customers are paying them for good
service with the tips I would say that
yes um we we're in a tip pool um so so
none of our employees work harder than
the other so um I think that the the
customers paying for the service that
they get you know the speed the quality
the smile the information that they get
um when they're asking about the menu um
clearing the plates making sure that
they have a seamless transaction um so
yeah I think that's what they're tipping
for thanks you very much
yes any other
questions reprentative Schultz I'm on
the I'm not able to ask a real question
because I'm a co-sponsor of the bill I
just wanted to know the name of your
restaurant oh yeah we're called the
green beautiful say that again the the
thank any others yes representative
bushard uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question and I
just want to commend you on on your
restaurant
and um by increasing the minimum wage
does that allow your workers to to stay
longer employed with
you I would I would think so yes um so
as because I started them at 15 like I
said it's now my job to navigate raises
because it's always incentivizing to to
continue to make more as you grow with a
company if I had started at the
$725 um I think that them getting more
hourly would it would incentivize them
to stay longer CU they would see that
every single week in their paycheck um
an example I think of that when I owned
a food truck in Portland Oregon um when
I got there when we opened in 2019 their
minimum wage was
$12.75 and um that next year it was
actually raised to about 1325 I believe
I got um like a notification it it went
up and and I was I saw how that affected
my employees at the time and they were
very very excited you know it was it was
out of my hands but I was happy to do it
and it was like kind of like a sense of
camaraderie and I knew they deserved it
so it was it was a nice moment and that
all any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you very
much
um next up and I am going to have
trouble with your name again and I
promis last last time I figure out how
ctis Viola catun that's right there I
had help um speaking in support of the
bill representing
gsop yes I am um good afternoon members
of the House committee labor committee
my name is Viola for the record and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
I'm here representing the gr State
organizing project we are a nonpartisan
grassroot organization
that brings people together to work
towards a more just World in New
Hampshire uh we are here today in
support of HB 1322 to raise the minimum
wage to $17 an hour by
2029 we know that uh the data that was
shared by the representative Kathy tab
um I'm not going to go back through the
numbers but I just wanted to highlight
that number which shows that about
124,000 Gran Staters who work work for
low wages uh and every day we hear from
the committe members and representatives
across the state that say no one works
for low wages in New Hampshire but
that's the reality that's the data uh we
also know um according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics a report from 2022 that
about 5,000 New Hampshire workers work
either at $725 an hour or below that and
4,000 of those are earing at $725 cents
an hour again reflecting uh the kind of
uh people in our communities who are not
making
it uh we know that newshire wage does
default the federal minimum wage uh
which has not really been raised since
2009 uh while the prices of goods and
services uh rent health care costs
everything else goes up every year and
there and that hasn't
stops uh so New Hampshire's wage is very
low and it needs to go much higher
there's nowhere in the state of New
Hampshire where anyone can leave for
$725 an hour uh the recent report from
the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority do show that the medium rent
and utility for a two-bedroom apartment
is
1,764 per month to afford that someone
needs to be making over 70,000 an hour I
mean 70,000 a year uh so the reality of
what people are earning and what the
cost of living is is very
clear uh but enough with the numbers and
I just want to share a few stories uh
that gsop is very familiar with we work
in different communities ities uh every
day we are talking to people on the
doors on the phones people coming to our
office and telling us what's going on
and people are hiding and so some of the
stories I have today I'm not going to
mention names but I just want to show
you the reality of the people that are
not able to be here because they're
working and what they're going through
um an example is a single mother of four
kids uh her rent went up 7ou 700 this
year starting in January just after
Christmas um that's a 25% increase So
currently she's paying $2,000 uh $300
per month uh she works as a property
manager but she's already sacrificing
enough uh to make sure that she takes
care of her kids and takes care of her
day-to-day living but how much more can
she sacrifice this is someone who's
working again they're not staying home
they're not waiting for anyone to help
them they're trying to make it work for
their own family and their Community but
she's struggling to make it at the
current rate that she's earning um
another individual that's making a
dollar or two above the minimum wage uh
she actually works for a Dollar Tree
store and the choice that she had to
make was to live with multiple people
because she can't afford to live by
herself she would want one-bedroom
apartment two bedroom apartment but
that's not something that's feasible to
them and they're working fulltime so
while some of us are sitting here and
wondering if we need a minimum wage the
reality is people Inaba need a minimum
wage and I want to challenge anyone here
if you think that we don't need it I
would like you to live on $725 an hour
for a week and tell me how you make it
out if you don't go to the food uh to
the food pantry if you don't ask for any
assistance i' would love to know if you
are successful in that because a lot of
people who are working have to go and
look for services um because they can
make it on the current
rate so with that i' would like to
encourage you to raise the minimum wage
because it does benefit workers it
benefits local businesses and it's the
right thing to do um protecting workers
who have been been left behind cuz at
the same time if we don't put that
regulation or that that protection for
workers if businesses decide to pay
$725 they will most business do pay
higher but some do stick to $725 and
that's not fair so I add you to vote Yes
on HB 1322 and and vote all to pass on
the bill thank you very much for your
time thank you for your testimony are
there questions for this
Witness pres McKenzie and uh turn on
your microphone so it gets on the
recording yep there we
committee so can can you say that the
the uh group that you're working with
people that you come in contact are
actually making $725 an hour in their
workplaces they are making slightly more
than $725 $12 $11 $13 but they're still
struggling with the current cost of
living mostly rent they're paying more
than 50 60% of their income to rent
because we know the current housing
market everywhere across the state is
pretty much high right
now
followup so the the there are people in
this economy who are suffering um and
come in contact with many of the people
in
um so there are this is a reality for
many people it's not something that well
with minimum wage of the wage 1518 an
hour you're dealing with people who are
at the lower end of the scale yeah
absolutely uh and if anyone is in doubt
I would like to invite you to our office
we always have uh people walking in
every Wednesday we have we run the
tenant Clinic uh people come in and just
come to help to get help assistance with
rent uh and we we really don't do
uh service work we do organizing and
advocacy uh but they come in because we
are a friendly environment that has
really is trying to change policies but
also we know resources connect them to
and so if you're in doubt of anyone that
who doesn't who makes low wages and you
want to hear or meet that person I'll be
happy to connect you with them and so
you can hear their stories but yes it's
all
right any further
questions seeing none thank you very
you next I would call on Henry V veu um
he's speaking for
minutes thank you uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Henry veu and I'm here on
behalf of the lodging and Restaurant
Association um and our opposition U
largely comes out of um
the section that deals with tipped
employees um as as was mentioned a lot
of our businesses are paying above the
725 um so the hourly rate isn't as much
of an issue um it's it's the section on
the the tipped employees um and when you
think about the minimum wage statute
it's protective
legislation right we're trying to
protect uh the lowest wage earners we
want to make sure there's a floor there
by which it doesn't go below and that's
U that's what should happen
um but when you look at the tipped
employees um although they're they're in
the minimum wage statute they're not
minimum wage earners um they're
typically uh they the highest take-home
uh earnings uh in a restaurant on um and
so the the problem we have with the bill
is increasing it from 45 to
50% of uh the minimum yes the employer
pays a low cash wage uh and they they
make they take home most of their money
in tips I mean that's how they earn
their wages um but they're considered
wages uh their tax the employer pays the
the FICA tax on those tips so
uh they're considered wages um and so we
don't think it's necessary for the
second part of the bill beginning on
line 17 to increase uh the tip wage
because again they're
not minimum W they're their highest uh
wage earners in the in the restaurant uh
business so that's my testimone you
probably have heard it 100 times uh I
was saying something we should just cut
right to the chase you guys exec vote 10
to 10 we get this to the
[Laughter]
floor thank you for the advice uh are
there questions for this witness
representative L
Clair yeah thanks for your testimony and
for taking my question would you be uh
you said that right now it's 45% of the
minimum wage the minimum wage for
servers yes would you be okay with
45% per increase or you wanted to just
stay at what I wanted to keep where it
is keep it where it is in the in the
statute all right
thanks uh representative
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Vu um I'm not confusing you with
Deputy Commissioner lers of the
unemployment but could you tell me if uh
do you know if if a if a uh server loses
the job you know maybe the closes or
something do you know if their benefits
are calculated on their total wages or
just the
327 that they've been paid uh I can
check um again it's a good question for
um commissioner
labors um I believe that I will check
and confirming it back to you uh that
it's on the total
um total reported yeah total reported
thank
you further
questions
further indicate that when somebody
works they have to work at least 80% of
the
time oh as uh so if they were work more
than
20% not uh doing what a server typically
does uh so I this camera here I think
what you're talking about and
referencing is if you have um a server
come in uh a tip server uh coming in and
there's an instance where um uh there
may not be enough business and they have
them doing what an hourly uh employee
would typically do
um uh which might be filling the salt
shakers or whatever not uh dealing
directly with customers um and uh the
hourly rate uh that needs to be paid
versus the
327 doing that versus the 725 is that
what you're referencing is that your
so it's uh
[Music]
employees correct and then their
overtime rate is also based on they
working they
that
Bas
correct
yeah any further questions
representative Clair thank you
um kind of going back to what I asked
earlier and it might be a two-part
question if I may yeah sure um the
restaurant has to pay the difference
between uh the tip wage and the minimum
wage correct if they don't make it if
they don't make it I I mean I I'm not
aware
of of a lot in that happens right I get
it so wouldn't it be wouldn't it benefit
the employer if the minimum wage did go
up
that the minimum wage follow suit
because then it would be less for that
employer to have to
fill uh again typically the amount of
tips that a server gets uh is more than
uh the minimum so the instance that you
are citing I don't think occurs uh often
right yeah well well if I may follow up
kind of follow up to what um
representative McKenzie just spoke about
you know if you have those couple hours
where you're rolling silverware
Etc now you have to pay the if the
minimum wage would to go up you'd have
to pay that I think instead uh you know
a good uh business owner manager will
manage it in such a way that he's going
to make sure that he doesn't have
servers coming in um right uh doing the
kind of work that you're describing that
he has the right people coming in doing
the right jobs so yeah and it just
depends on how busy the restaurant is at
a particular time right right thank you
questions we're trying to find out if
question
and I I understand that that's the way
we modify the house I'm just thinking
always than the
current the
to
and you want to clarify for the
committee it will
be if this happens on future bills where
people know
uh one of the upcoming bills and want to
debate I obviously can't stop
that okay do you want to clarify for
folks no that's goad um Mr ve good to
see you as always um to clarify a little
bit further from what the two previous
reps were asking um I'm aware of at
least five or six cases that the US
Department of Labor has brought against
um unfortunately new restaurants owners
for not paying them
properly um to follow up on what lir was
suggesting wouldn't it just be better to
um eliminate tipped wages in general so
that this the large fines that
restaurants uh are incurring um because
that it is complicated and it's easy to
do the wrong thing I guess wouldn't it
just be better to get rid of tips wages
knowing so many restaurants are paying a
hefty fines thank you representative
Schultz uh for the question uh that's a
a big issue that we could talk uh for
quite a bit on the whole business model
the idea of uh having servers uh make
the majority of their wages through tips
I think that's your question should we
continue to do that or should we just
change the whole business model and have
the servers make uh uh the minimum um I
do know that years uh I think it was in
the late
201s I I can look at it but in
Maine uh there was a ballot item to go
to the minimum wage for the servers and
it passed and a year later the servers
showed up at the State House to ask that
it be
uh uh repealed than it was largely
because they prefer
to have the system where they make
majority on their tips I think they and
maybe it's because it's just the way
um follow I simply was gonna point out
that's the exact same thing you raised
the last time we talked about this you
and I at one of these hearings um it is
my understanding that polls of New
Hampshire
servers um actually they're in support
of getting rid of the tip wage
designation I don't know had you heard
that I don't know what polls but I'm
sure there is a poll that you are
you representative McKenzie thank you uh
uh one final question uh I had a
professor in in grad school said you
can't put a number on it it doesn't
exist so in that line uh I've heard you
come before this committee before and
say that uh that the wages for tipped
employees are such and such and they
make more and that kind of stuff do you
have empirical evidence have you done uh
surveys uh are you able to prove that
and lay that up because I'm not sure
that's something that's going to be
tracked necessarily by the finement
public
security data uh so can you produce that
for the commit yeah I mean I've talked
to a lot of the restaurant operators and
I've asked them that question what you
know what uh are the tipped employees
and again you've got the high-ends you
know your copper door and Bedford those
tip servers are going to be making 30
some odd dollars an hour uh you got your
mid-range uh and then you got your lower
rate so there's clearly a range of um
what tip servers are taking home and pay
uh but in just about all the inst it's
well above the minimum wage again my
point here today is minimum wage is a
protective piece of legislation Mr
okay your question was what I'm sorry I
didn't answer your question
representative McKenzie um your question
um we've asked uh Employment Security um
for that information um I don't think
they have it but I guess I would
ask when you go into a restaurant um
maybe I pose the question to one of the
servers that they take
on so I could thank you Mr chair
so if I take what I can take away from
that is that there is that you have not
surveyed the restaurants you don't
necessarily have empirical evidence to
support which you have said on more than
one occasion in front of this committee
that they make so much more money uh
which leads one to believe that
everybody in that industry is making
those kinds of things like a Copa do so
if if you don't have it you don't have
it um but I think it uh you know my
sense is that it would be helpful uh for
this commit to understand U you know if
that's actually a true uh representation
what's happening in thank you I know the
National Restaurant Association does a
lot I mean the New Hampshire Restaurant
Association is a small outfit they got
five people um they're not doing all
these empirical studies but the National
Restaurant Association which has more
resources I think has done some of that
and I can try to get you National Data
which it's all pretty much the same the
IND industry pretty much operates the
same um so I can get you some empirical
data it won't probably be New Hampshire
Pacific uh because the New Hampshire
Association isn't some large operation
it's a pretty small operation thank you
Mr are there any other questions
representative
love thank you for taking my question
um if if to keep the numbers round if a
a small restaurant has 10 employees and
uh the uh the the difference in in wages
say $200 an employee and we got a $2,000
a week um difference here uh who's who's
going to be supporting that who's who's
going to be paying that uh the
customer and uh
follow uh how much would that uh how
much trouble that that put on these
small businesses to to stay in business
um you know in in today's business
climate oh you're talking about if we
moved the tipped wage up to the minimum
and what the impact would be I mean yeah
ultimately um if you're going to
radically change the business model and
have the tipped employees pay the
minimum then um it's got to come out of
someplace and it'll come through the
menu
prices because the margins aren't big in
the
industry just one more followup just to
just to clarify uh so so a small small
business small restaurant would have a
very difficult time staying in business
if their their prices kept going up and
uh you know for I mean uh it's different
for we heard from a uh restaurant
operator in Manchester uh that she does
it um and that's that's pretty
impressive that's good um there were
some me members of the New Hampshire
lodging restaurant associate that tried
it in Dober worked for a little while
and then they they went back back uh to
the the uh C minimum cash wage but um
it's probably um maybe a marketing
Advantage for her which is good I don't
know but for a lot of do you answer your
question I got to start answering
questions directly um yeah I'm sure it's
going to be it would be difficult for a
lot of small
operators any f ah we have more
questions representative kahill thank
you Mr chair and thank you m Mr veu for
uh taking yet another question
um uh a a restaurant owner that I'm
aware of I think we when we talked about
tip wages previously said something
about that they raise prices 6% every
year that's just sort of normal and I
know that with all the uh Supply
problems and cost of you know eggs Food
everything else that prices have also
gone up and that the yes the customer
has paid for that and they continue to
do that because the restaurant industry
is having a pretty good year um but
isn't as also true that when you when
the restaurant prices go up the taxes
now8 and a half% uh the state receives
more revenue and the restaurant
operators get the 3% of that tax so they
also get another little incentive uh it
doesn't sort of doesn't that soften the
blow of the
increase I so I think representative
Cahill is referring to an issue that
comes up in the Ways and Means Committee
a lot uh with the rooms and males tax so
he's referring to um so the restaurant
operator collects a rooms of mailes tax
for the state and uh when it was uh
initiated back in the 60s or whatever it
was uh they said if you in the statute
it says you have to pay you have to
remit the taxes to the state by the 15th
day of of the following month and if you
do so you can retain 3% of the tax
collected that's you're referring to
you're saying when menu prices go up and
blah blah blah and that 3% grows it's
not a lot of money um but if you want me
to say you're correct I'll say you're
correct thank you Mr ve is it also true
that that
05% uh lowering of that reals and rooms
tax also
uh reduce the amount the the uh
customers were able to keep you mean the
business yeah yeah I mean it's largely
so when you think about most people put
uh they they pay for the meals uh with a
credit card right most people pay a
credit card
well there's a there's a uh what is it
for the rates that you pay the credit
card companies just keep going up and so
we're collecting this tax for the state
and the business operator has that
expense of having to pay the credit card
company for taking the credit card so
the businesses aren't making money on
the 3% they're basically just covering
state so pay so bring cash when you go
to the restaurant then yes then you'll
be doing your restaurant operator a
service you're on the record bring cash
thank you
are there more
oh again in this case we have we'll have
an opportunity to debate this bill when
it comes to the committee we have a
number of other people who have come
here to testify
I um have signed in we're we're past the
time allotted to this bill if
you really feel we need to discuss that
issue I would offer that maybe we can
call the sponsor up after we get through
the other people who are waiting in line
um so at this point questions to the
person who is speaking please and and
think ahead if it's something that's
going to be part of a debate and you
want the point made to help pass the
bill we will have time in committee to
have those discussions than
you so uh for represent or for uh the
witness are there further
questions and seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony
um next I have a card from Reverend Dr
Gail Kenny who is representing the New
Hampshire United Church of Christ
speaking in support of the bill for
three
minutes thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Gail Kenny I'm a resident of Kanan
and I am a pastor with the United Church
of Christ um the United Church of Christ
um many of you may also you know know
the individual churches as local
congregational churches it is the
largest Protestant denomination in New
Hampshire and um the the UCC we also
known as the UCC so I'm I'll probably
use that so um UCC members and churches
were shocked back in
2011 on when the uh New Hampshire
legislature the general court at the
time in its wisdom decided to wipe a
minimum wage statute off the books and
um so we thought that okay maybe this is
just a fluke and that it will be
corrected when a new legislature comes
to town so um 2013 rolled around and
nothing happened and so and then 2014
the second year of the session and so um
the the um the UCC as a whole in a um a
Statewide Gathering passed a very
strongly worded resolution that I've
actually given to this committee over
time so I won't do it again for the sake
of paper um but very strong resolution
urging a reinstatement of uh minimum
wage and moving expeditiously toward a
living wage for New Hampshire workers um
so because I've heard before uh in this
committee and elsewhere that oh well a
minimum wage is just a training wage
it's just for kids um I want to just
State for the record again that the
minimum wage was never intended when it
was first um implemented um way back
when to be a training wage it was meant
to be a floor below which no full-time
worker should ever fall um to a point
where they couldn't meet their basic
needs um so it was meant to be the
minimum that would allow somebody to
live and allow somebody to thrive so um
so for 15 years now first with the the
wage on the books in New Hampshire at
725 back in 2011 and then since then um
there has been just an absolute refusal
on the part of um the the legislature to
do anything about that floor knowing
full well that if 725 was an appropriate
floor uh um in 2009 it is no we're near
that in
2024 so my question is what is the
message uh that this legislature is
sending to workers who want to come into
New Hampshire and to Young workers that
we are in desperate need of in this
state and by indicating through just a
refusal even to reinstate a minimum wage
and to do anything about it um that it
the message to me is that New Hampshire
devalues work and so um as a as a basic
matter of public policy
um we the the United Church of Christ
strongly strongly strongly urges this
committee this time around not to do the
same old thing but to think very
seriously about what is the message that
this the the green um portion that um
represent the sponsor provided to all of
you look at the numbers it is an
embarrassment for New Hampshire to be
where we are um less than 50% of what
the minimum wage is in um Connecticut
and M Massachusetts that that's really a
moral atrocity um and I just the final
thing I want to say about the bill is
that we really we look at this bill um
and we appreciate um the fact that it's
being introduced um yet again it is
modest frankly it is nowhere near enough
and we recognize that for people in New
Hampshire to thrive but it's a start and
we really encourage you to uh to look at
this seriously and to make this start
for the sake of all workers in New
Hampshire just sort of one final thing I
want to say is that um if workers
particularly in the lodging and
restaurant industry are doing so well
and if Employers in order to just get
workers so they don't have to close
their doors have to pay much more than
the minimum already then what difference
does it make what will it matter to
those businesses to raise the minimum
wage and make it a living wage um that
would affect you know not just them but
those businesses who are already playing
pay much more than that but to all the
other people that are still making $725
or $8 or $825 or $9 an hour I I don't
understand the opposition at this point
when the um lodging and restaurant
employers are already doing so well and
paying so well but I thank you for your
time and I would very very um strongly
implore you on the behalf of the United
Church of Christ to vote this ought to
pass thank you for your testimony are
right uh so the next card I have and I
have two remaining so if there was
somebody planning to speak and um I
don't have your card yet please pass it
up um next up is Claudia Estelle uh
representing herself and speaking in
support of the mill for three or four
minutes
thank you very much I'm Claudia stelle
from aworth and I'm also a member of the
economic Justice Mission group of the
United Church of Christ and the moral
economy table um as a person of faith I
believe that every worker deserves
respect and a living wage for their
labor every member of the society should
feel
valued and be able to earn a decent
living that allows them to provide basic
needs for themselves and their families
food clothing housing communication
trans Transportation Medical Care and
education numerous studies in in various
Fields highlight the intersectionality
of these areas supporting what our
Common Sense already tells us people who
are financially secure have better
health because they are food and housing
secure that allows them to be able to be
better Learners and be because they can
focus on the subject at hand rather than
worrying about their hunger or how
they're going to pay their bills
reliable transportation and good health
lead to better attendance and all these
lead to better job performance more
productive workers benefit the economy
and workers who feel valued and don't
have to worry about food housing Health
transportation and Financial Security
can devote more time to enriching the
lives of their families and
participating in in their communities I
don't think this is a polyana view of
the world I think this is a moral view
where every human H has a right to earn
a decent living to be respected to be
given dignity for their positive
contributions to their family work and
Community because they are human
beings unfortunately in New Hampshire
this is a right that is shared by maybe
half of our
workers you've already heard a lot about
the um MIT living wage calculator we've
spoken about that today and
previously um that means that people
would have to be earning at least 20 $
an hour if you have a two adult working
family and supporting themselves and a
child we also know that and and I would
add to that that that calculator was
based using uh an amount of only a
little under $1,400 for housing where we
already know that housing in New
Hampshire for a two-bedroom apartment is
over $1,700 a month in addition we have
one in four households in New Hampshire
that earn less than $50,000 a year and
177% are under $35,000 a year this puts
an enormous Financial pressure on these
families to meet basic needs of food and
else in terms of hourly wages I already
said that a living wage in New Hampshire
is well over $20 an hour if if you have
two people contributing to the household
um and I just want to point out that the
poverty rate in New Hampshire is $1
15,22 for a single person if you divide
that by 2,000 hours of work a year that
comes out to an hourly wage of over
$760 which means it's above the minimum
wage that we have in New Hampshire in
other words we consider our minimum wage
a poverty wage we're accepting that and
I don't think that that's
right we have um we've already heard
about the the minimum people earning the
minimum wage poverty and financial
insecurity are very real in our state we
have a 7% poverty rate in New Hampshire
which we probably think of as being
pretty good because it's a it's among
the lowest in the country I question
from a moral perspective if any poverty
rate is
acceptable the poverty picture in New
Hampshire very Aries by County Coos and
Sullivan County having well over 11%
poverty and by groups more men and women
and more men and um women and children
are in poverty than men and the elderly
rate is currently about 7% but if we
talk to anybody who works with elderly
people it is
rising the largest number of poor people
are actually in a county that doesn't
have a lot of doesn't have a high
poverty rate Hillsboro County and that's
population and among those who live in
poverty one and three are disabled so
working one's way out of poverty isn't
always an option if one is disabled or
elderly or can't find affordable child
care or doesn't have reliable
transportation or has a part-time job
with unpredictable schedule and can't
schedule a new second job they can't
work their way
out the other thing I'd like to bring to
your attention is that one and three
granite Staters last year said that it
was difficult or very difficult to meet
normal household expenses one and three
27% of New Hampshire households do not
have $2,000 in savings I have a friend
who was considering going into
bankruptcy because she couldn't pay off
a
bill and we all know the kind of um what
that would do to her credit crit rating
for years to
come
so um we've we're past the major part of
the pandemic when people had a lot of
extra
income and what's H and wages have
increased but they haven't kept up with
inflation and two places where they have
where they have not kept up is in
education and in health services and
those two areas are among our largest
employers in this State and the places
where we constantly need more
workers so I really encourage you please
to consider raising the minimum wage
this $17 an hour we know is not a living
wage but it's a vast improvement over
where we are now the tipped uh W moving
the tipped wages to 50% would also be a
big help to our least paid workers and
um the economic policy Institute points
out that uh this bill would improve the
124,000 people or one in six Granite
State Workers please vote this bill
ought to pass thank you thank you for
questions seeing none thank you oh we do
have a question Mrs D if I see you have
it typed could we have that
copy yes and I emailed it to the
committee but I'm but I'm not positive
if you got it because our internet went
out but I will give this to you that
would be great thank you you're
welcome yes thank you for
that um any other questions seeing none
thank you again for your testimony um
the last card I have is City councelor
Karen and I can't read them the Kill Leo
Karen Leo Hill okay from Lebanon yes
great thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Karen leoh Hill
I'm a 19-year city councelor in Lebanon
and the former mayor I'm also the
grafting County
Treasurer I think when I was first
elected in 2005 $15 was designated as
the um living wage at the time so 20
years later I can imagine that what uh
the previous uh testimony said that it
now is over $20 an hour I'm not
surprised New Hampshire faces a
Workforce crisis and as we all know uh
we see that in the city of Lebanon as
well particularly among lower wage
workers the um inability to recruit and
retain workers affects the entire
economy having a vibrant economy relies
on uh having a having a Workforce at all
levels but especially uh especially
among lower wage workers the um home
health aids the grocery store clerks the
all of the people in retail people who
are on you know the Frontline
workers and we know that a rising tide
raises all boats I think if I got that
expression correct uh and when we uh
when we raise the minimum wage it also
has an uh an effect on wages at all
levels and so I'm here to encourage you
to support raising this is a very modest
uh proposal does not even really get to
the issue of a living wage but it does
send a message that um that New
Hampshire cares about lower wage workers
and it does uh it it is the kind of
policy by increasing the wage uh the
minimum wage it also has um a virtuous
impact on the economy by making it more
possible for people at the lower levels
to be able to afford housing in Lebanon
the median income the the medium uh
$500,000 we know the minimum wage has
not improved in uh has not increased in
New Hampshire
um at all let alone to allow lower wage
workers to be able to um live within
their own communities so I urge you to
um work on this bill make improvements
where necessary um but I am here to
offer my testimony and support of
raising this very modest proposal to
raise the minimum wage in New Hampshire
I think it's beyond time thank you thank
questions seeing none thank you again um
that was the last card I had so if there
are no other cars to be submitted um
sheet while I'm waiting we heard once
again from will he was almost here and
uh got called back on an emergency so
I'm afraid everyone is stuck with me for
bills and I don't have any cards yet for
the next bill which will begin
immediately and there I see the sponsor
thank
you
Z this one isn't stable but that's the
top one only all right so this goes this
the um
and for the last uh Bill we had a number
of sign in 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 um
people signed in for the bill and one
two three four
against um I don't have the online and
our committee researcher is not in today
so
um that will continue to be available so
I
encourage uh members of this committee
to check
that
and with that um I will close the
hearing on HB
1322 and we'll immediately open the
1668 and I rep recognize the sponsor of
that
Bill thank you Mr U acting chair and
thank you honorable members of the
committee for welcoming me to your
committee uh for the record my name is
Ellen Reid I represent the towns of new
fields and New
Market um so I have before you today a
bill that would establish the 32h hour
work week as full-time meaning any hours
worked over um 32 hours would be uh
would qualify for time and a half over
time this is coupled with no loss in pay
so that a full-time worker who um
whatever they making currently in their
full-time position they would still be
making that amount for a 32-hour work
week this represents a 25% increase in
Pay I won't go into all of the virtues
of increasing pay and why we need to
increase pay in general since you've
just heard a very long hearing on the
same matter um I will just say once
again that
economies are built bottom up and when
you bring up the bottom you bring up the
entire economy so increases in Pay um
are helpful especially in our state
where we are suffering from a housing
crisis that is the cause of the um graay
of New Hampshire crisis um those two
things are basically the one and same
one in the same crisis So to that extent
this is um this increase in pay would be
extremely helpful having said that um
eight other states have prepared
proposed this legislation uh this is
pulled directly from the
Pennsylvania uh proposed legislation and
it has also been proposed federally as
well also countless municipalities have
already um shifted to a 4-day work week
including my own municipality as a
matter of fact um and many
municipalities in the state um because
it helps attract and retain
workers uh also several New Hampshire
businesses have um already changed
voluntarily over to a 4-day work week
work it daily and the Morrison Community
which is a senior um housing uh company
both have changed over as well as others
so the benefits of switching to a
32-hour work week um are numerous uh as
you would expect the benefits for
workers are uh a lot so 95% of workers
who have worked in a pilot 4-day uh
workweek program have um wanted to
continue that but wait till I get to the
employers um because they experience a
69% reduction and burnout and all of
this data will be found in this report
that I have passed out which studies
over a 12-month period the pilot
programs over numerous companies in both
the United States and Canada um workers
also experience 74% % more work life
balance satisfaction and they have
increased time and this is very
important we heard a lot about this they
have increased time to care for their
loved ones whether their loved ones are
their aging parents or their children or
maybe their animals or whomever um
having that work life balance is
important employers though I said 95% of
employees wanted to continue the 4-day
trial 100% of employers who trial a
4-day work week wanted to and did
continue it um the reason they
experienced no loss in Revenue um they
had increased employee productivity so
more productivity in 32 hours than they
had experienced in 40 hours and they had
increased employee retention and
satisfaction happier work environments
less
turnover in addition uh to benefiting
employees and benefiting employers it
also benefits society as a whole there
is an environmental impact when you have
people only commuting four days a week
instead of five but the mental health
impact is
significant um for the well-being of the
population as a whole also people tend
to share home responsibilities more
evenly uh regardless of gender when
people have time at home they both
engage in uh child care and taking care
of the home
also um and this is kind of going to get
into the the philosophy of this
so we have currently a system where if
you say automation it's a scary word
especially for workers and that doesn't
really quite make sense to me because if
you imagine let's say a a village and
everyone's engaged in work constantly to
make that Village go they're fishing
they're farming what have you and then
you drop into this Village a bunch of
robots to do all of that work that is a
blessing to that Village that's a boom
to them all of a sudden they have free
time to do other things because now
their needs are being met by these
machines and yet in our current economic
structure automation does the opposite
it threatens the ability of people to
meet their basic needs because now they
are worried about losing a job now think
about this as an employer you actually
have two decisions if you choose to buy
automated automated
technology um and we're we're going to
say that the cost of the technology is
the same in either scenario you buy some
technology that automates the work you
employ a certain number of people now
that you've bought this technology you
now have only half of the requirement of
Labor that you previously had the answer
normally in our current system is to lay
off half of your
workers that makes a lot of people
unhappy why do that you are paying the
same in
labor but half as you would if you've
simply said everyone keeps their jobs
everyone stays uh at the same pay but
works half the
time so why do we do that to people why
do we make something that should help us
actually work against
us um for what it's worth medieval under
I'm not suggesting we go back to
feudalism at all but medieval workers
medieval peasants only worked 150 days a
year like
like like 60% of what we we work today
more so in every period of human
development where we were the most
productive it was a period where we had
the most Leisure I know that there's a a
narrative that says that well if you
don't make people work Con constantly
then they're going to be lazy not going
to do anything if you just you know if
they have enough but the thing is is
that periods like the Renaissance when
we did the most it's because we had the
most Leisure it's because we had our
needs met with a minimal amount of work
and it turns out humans are we get
Restless you might rest for a while but
you want to start studying something or
learning something or learning a an
instrument or a language people become
resourceful and Innovative when you give
them Leisure having extra leisure time
benefits society as a whole as well as
individuals and honestly I don't I don't
know I think we are experiencing a
moment in our society right now where
people are pretty much done with the
concept that they have been or are being
forced to sell their labor for half of
all of their waking hours from the time
their bodies are fully formed as adults
until the times their bodies are
breaking down in old age and that's the
situation we have and it gets to a point
when you having to work so much that
life doesn't seem to have a meaning
you're you're working to live but you're
also just living to work you get off at
5: and you you go and you get the kids
food and you do the things that you know
you barely get the things done that you
need to do to survive and then you rush
you go to bed you wake up and you do it
again I will also say this extra
productivity this extra happiness that
occurs when you give people more Leisure
Time and the Leisure Time that comes
with increased productivity from
technology is actually what caused us to
be an economic superpower in the first
place the moving to the 40-hour work
week which happened in
1940 was a result of a it was part of a
whole bunch of reforms that happened
after the Great Depression or that
helped get us out of the Great
Depression and it created the strongest
economy in the world because we were
more productive
and since that time our productivity in
large part because of technology has
increased over
60% and yet we're still even with that
technology we're still being forced into
half of all of our waking hours for the
work
week so in short and I you know thank
you for tolerating my waxing philosophic
for a bit but um this is a triple
dividend it's a win-win win it helps
workers OB viously it helps employers
and it helps society as a whole because
no one you know imagine having time to
actually live whatever it is you think
the purpose of your life is to live to
your fullest whatever you define it when
you have extra time you travel or you
read or you learn new skills or develop
relationships or you know work on
yourself you actually live your life and
that's what's really important to to
people so it helps workers it helps
employers and it helps society and it's
proven itself from industry to Industry
consistently and I do encourage you to
please peruse the report because it is
quite thorough and with that I am I I
understand this may be the first time
this concept has been heard by this
committee or or this um legislative
branch for that matter but I appreciate
you engaging in conversation with me
about this concept and I will take
questions
thank you very much for your testimony I
do have a question uh just to clarify
the title of the bill is for a 4-day
work week but when I read the language
it's not specific so you could if I'm
reading correctly meet this by reducing
having a five-day work week but sixh
hour days for example am I is is that
correct in terms of your intent yes and
like I said this language is directly
out of the Pennsylvania proposed
legislation so just like you can meet 40
hours in 4 days or 5 days currently you
could meet 32 hours in any number of
days all right thank you uh further
questions representative
Susi thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question so it says it
mandates why wouldn't we have um
enabling legislation
because I'm assuming that enabling
legislation may
help um companies that this may not be a
um Bill well this may not be legislation
that's one size fits all right enabling
legislation as I understand it typically
um refers to the fact that we're a
dyan's rle state and that would be
enabling municipalities which um
municipalities are already enabled to do
this and private sector is already
enabled I guess you would say already
free to do this as they have currently
but just like we had to legislate moving
from the six day work week back in the
20s and actually it was Henry Ford that
realized that moving from the six day to
the 5-day work week was beneficial and
famously um having his employees be able
to have the Leisure and afford to buy
his own product was a strong motivating
factor um but that legislative
requirement to move the entire indust or
the entire uh private sector over was
necessary to actually see those benefits
because it turns out that private actors
don't always necessarily do the right
thing or know the right thing
thank
you further questions representative
suvin you mentioned the several states
have uh proposes this legislation have
any of those States adopted this uh
legislation no one's adopted it yet
thank
you it's considered
represent
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question thank
you you I was kind of reading through
this while you were talking um one of
the things you mentioned is employers
found no loss in revenue and actually in
here I think those was a spot that said
actually they increase it by 15% or
something yeah I didn't want to speak
for every employer we've seen it be
successful from industry to Industry the
implementation depending on the industry
to rep su's Point um can be different
but every industry has been successful
but at a bare minimum no no one has
experienced a loss of Revenue because of
it um some sectors have experienced an
increase and thank you very much for
pointing that out okay that wasn't even
my question I just oh sorry no that's
fine is does this proposed Bill
match what they did in the
study uh so as I understand in the study
it's a study of every company that they
could track in the US and Canada that
did any kind of 4-day work week pilot
program so um all of those programs
would be different according to the
individual business but in by and large
yes okay one more question okay so what
I was wondering now is if there was no
difference in revenue and actually maybe
some did increase it didn't say anything
about um expenditures going up or down
is there data on
that if the report doesn't have it it's
something I can certainly ask to get the
only sorry the only reason I'm asking is
the other portion for
profit well yes for profit but I was
wondering because um this also changes
the overtime pay so an employee Works
more than eight hours in a single day
now the business is on the hook for
overtime or 12 hours in double time so
my question would be well I guess in my
mind I can just think of a lot of
different Industries and even
municipalities where the eight hours and
then they're paying more it's going to
be a significant increase in expenses so
I wasn't sure if that was brought up in
the report at all so the the public
sector is different from the private
sector and the public sector doesn't
have to profit and um and and really
shouldn't but as we've seen in the
public sector many many municipalities
have already taken that move on their
own um and and by the way moving to a
4-day work week doesn't mean moving to
four days of operation and in some cases
you actually you still operate five or
even seven days a week you may have more
employees which is actually beneficial
um but I presume and can ask for more
data regarding this specifically that
the the um increase to flatlining of
Revenue um also meant at least no change
in profit because again 100% of
employers continued the program past the
pilot if they had experienced a sharp
increase in expenditures or a decrease
in profit I imagine that would have been
the very first thing they would have
done to be drop the pilot program I
guess if you can provide that I'm happy
to to get more information yes in fact
I'll make a note right now
representative thank you Mr chairman um
just the first question is how many
employees do you
have this feels rather factious but I
don't own a business and don't employ
anyone thank you um and Fallout Mr
chairman
um so if you have a fire department who
is Staff 24 hours a day um typically
they will work 12 or 24hour shifts um
this would increase their rate of pay
but also increase the tax liability for
the taxpayers have you thought that
through with this four day week work
week and mandates for
overtime I not only have I been aware
that that is an issue but so have the
many many many municipalities that have
already enacted it on their own own so
again moving to a 4-day work week um is
something they've done
voluntarily it does come with an
increase in pay and to um Industries
where you have to pay you know not just
for the you know several hours you know
that a normal business would be open but
in this case 24 hours a day and they
still do it and it still works across
the board then I'm I don't find that I
have the expertise to tell them that's
any further
questions I think I got off pretty easy
actually thank you very much for Tes
considering I do not have any other
cards on this bill um if we miss someone
please pass your card up and if not
sheet and um
this is mine for when we vote Yes
so it probably shouldn't be in my in
your
package
um so we have uh in the signups we have
three people who signed in in favor and
five people who signed in
against and with that I will close the
public hearing on
1668 the next public hearing is
scheduled for
1377 at this point it doesn't look like
we're going to exceed the capacity of
this room if a lot of people start
showing up uh as it gets close to three
I need to go talk to staff about what
was arranged um we might need to move to
a bigger room um so I will go find that
out otherwise we'll begin here at 3 o'
can
I for some privilege and welcome
honorable Jay W who be a member of this
again
ch
all right everybody I know that clock's
running a few minutes fast so I don't
think we're quite at 3:00 so I'll start
talking anyway
um so first of all because we knew we'd
be pushing the capacity of this room
what has been set up is upstairs from
here in room 307 their labor room
is going to be broadcasting this hearing
so if this room gets too crowded um
people are welcome to go up there and if
I have your name in to speak and you're
up there I'm going to try to read ahead
a couple of names so that people can you
know anybody even if you just want a
little more room to to relax and and
listen upstairs that's available to
everyone um as it looks right now I
don't think we have an emergency where
we have to push people out but just be
aware that that's
available um
secondly I oh and somebody what do we do
here there um have a lot of people who
want to talk and that's great um
but uh just keep in mind that we don't
want to be here all night so if you want
to say something but you've heard people
say the same thing before um please it
may not be necessary to repeat it maybe
just what what they said if you have
written testimony um turn that in the
clerk will put that into the record and
and try to summarize what you have
rather um than than read written
testimony um the other thing is I I flip
through these cards and almost everyone
I think I found two maybe three that
were different wrote down that they
wanted to speak for three minutes so um
I'd like to ask everyone to please stick
to that three minutes um and we'll kind
of be watching the clock and maybe maybe
wave if if people are going over time
and that will just make sure that
everyone's here we want everyone has a
chance get a chance to speak some people
are going to have to leave if we go on
too long and I don't want to have people
lose their opportunity to testify
because um they've run out of time so
with that I think we
are certainly and why don't you just say
it for ex I was just asking our chair um
I noticed for example one of our
executive counselors is here today so I
don't know if anyone has any constraints
in their own time we probably should be
aware of uh anybody that has to leave
for their responsibilities and whatnot I
just I don't know I assume she might but
and um just so people are aware what
we've been doing is as the cards go in
we've been putting in first in first out
so yes if somebody has some kind of
emergency constraint uh let me know and
and I'll I'll try to reshuffle
accordingly um so with that I will open
the hearing on HB
1377 and I will ask the sponsor to
Bill thank you Mr chair uh dear
committee members for the record uh my
name is representative Yuri po
representing Mary Mark 10 hookit and Dan
Barton I'm very thankful for the
opportunity to introduce HB
1377 FN also commonly known as a right
to work work uh the bill is written is
granting workers free choice to join or
refrain from joining labor unions uh it
fixes the current situation when workers
are forced to pay the union dues even if
they do not want to be part of the Union
do not agree with the Union goals
leadership self-serving expenditures or
financial financial support uh for a
certain
politician those mandatory fees hurt the
most financially valuable
constituents right to work is adopted by
a majority of states and when we compare
right to work states with states with
forced
unionism right to work is a win BN for
everyone so let's compare states with
forc unionism in general uh New
Hampshire specifically and uh right to V
States so right to walk states have at
least 7% points higher growth in number
of people employed they have at least
80% higher if we take private non-farm
sectors uh 7even at least 7% higher
growth in population 35 to 54 that New
Hampshire was
losing and 7 uh % higher real growth in
household
consumption and at least twice more new
private single unit housing
alization even opponents of the bill
recognize that this bill helps increase
the number of
employed but they counted it uh by
saying that the salaries are
lower it might be true uh for example in
forced restrictive States like
California
that salaries are in general higher in
California but uh what is even higher
cost of
living when we calculate cost of living
adjustment for private sector salaries
the difference goes away and even
reverses so slight difference of uh
employees in a right to work states
making a few hundred more in the past
New Hampshire was uh split on on this
isue New Hampshire was unsure uh but uh
this new scientific data from dozens of
states with a Right to Work legislation
shows that uh it is time so please
support this bill uh thank you and I'm
ready to answer any questions thank you
for your testimony are there any
questions for the
sponsor thank you um this is something
I'll ask anyone or you can just provide
it I see your remark Mar s are written
um as the clerk I would love to have a
copy thank
you any other
Susie thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for answering the
question can you please explain the bill
and what the impact would be regarding
law so a Bill allows workers to join or
not to join uh unions and uh it fixes
the situation when people are forced to
pay union dues even if they don't agree
with the goals of certain
Union and uh in terms
of large implications uh maybe you could
clarify your question but if uh I'm
missing something uh we will have more
knowledgeable people testifying after me
who can help answer the larger
implications any other
questions representative L Clair thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question too um so you said that um
people are forced to pay union dues have
you asked Union people if they're forced
definitely we have situations when
um we have uh union members who choose
to pay union dues but also we have
situations when people would rather
prefer
working uh without uh pay paying those
dues and not to be part of the
[Music]
Union follow up follow up
so I mean everybody has a choice right
to be part of a union or not be part of
a union if you don't want to work for a
particular job
that would rather have you be a union
member you don't have to work there is
that
correct um you can see at it that way
but um I'm seeing that
uh uh people should be free to work
without being forced to be part of the
Union
and
uh
Union Union has their freedom of uh be
being in Union and have their own
bargaining
agreements thank you representative
svin thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question are you familiar with
representation uh is it uh in in this
much
so the the
way I see it there there some um
misunderstanding about this term I don't
believe that
unions necessarily have duty to
represent those who are not paying
unions dues so uh that's how I
understand your question and
uh I think we have different
understanding on what's going on here
followup
followup are you aware that unions are
required to represent everyone that is
covered by their contract
therefore a union would have to um
represent dues paying members and non-u
paying
non-members
um I would agree with you that uh if
it's in a
contract the union might be obliged by
that contract but as far as I understand
uh the current situation the cont
way thank you represent
buard thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question
uh do you think it's fair for some
workers to benefit from collective
bargaining agreements without sharing
the
cost uh it's it's a uh thank you for
your question and uh yes it's a common
uh objection to right to work uh so uh I
think um some some people may perceive
uh uh it uh uh the same way as you
worded it but it is being fixed as I say
by the fact that uh conflict could be
constructed in that way so union doesn't
have to um represent uh those who are
not part of the unions and doesn't have
to include them in the same agreement so
I I think uh there are uh when if if if
it's if it's felt as unfair and Bome
it follow
up I I don't I don't believe that that
you can do that when you have a
collective bargaining bill you have to
represent
uh I believe it's the same question that
I answered before
uh
so I I don't have new
information representative brudy thank
you Mr chairman um do you think it's
right to ask somebody to do something
for you without compensating them if you
need something done and you force
somebody to help you
him
uh this bill
doesn't doesn't stop unions
from limiting or completely denying
amount of services that they provide to
those who are not paying them for those
services
follow up thank you Mr chairman so if if
you um don't want to belong to the union
but you need their
services don't you think it's right that
you pay for the services or do you
expect people to work for free and other
you I think it's could be solved on one
to one case if somebody suddenly feels
an urge uh to join the union bill
doesn't stop people from volunteer
joining the union and starting paying uh
the the fees or otherwise contributing
union representative love thank you for
taking my question you know back in the
70s I I had a job uh you know working on
a beer truck was a union job and uh the
business agent uh that was a pretty
contentious uh you know environment uh
labor related but uh the business agent
was going out to drink drink have liquid
lunch with the bosses three times a week
which left us in a a pretty rotten spot
uh at that time we could we could not
and even now today we could not say hey
until you start doing your job you're
not getting any more money we were being
forced to to buy a product that wasn't
serving us do you think that's
right right thank you um so I would
especially with a sponsor I think we
like to have more questions with the
sponsor of the bill I would remind the
committee that I've got a thick pile of
cards here and we're going to have a lot
of people talking on both sides of the
bill some of whom we'll agree with some
of whom will disagree with and I think
it would be better to let the people who
have come speak and make the points uh
not to cut off questions when you really
have them but be mindful of the number
of people that are here before us so I
thank you in advance for that if there
are there any other questions before the
SP for the
sponsor seeing none thank you and I said
I'd read ahead so um I'm going to next
call uh co-sponsor uh representative Dan
Maguire I'm going to call Rich Gula and
I'm GNA call Maggie
Fogerty and again I know some people
walked in after I said that one of the
reasons I'm doing that is we have set up
upstairs room 307 has a monitor so if it
gets too crowded here and people want a
little more space you can go up here and
and we'll make sure that you can still
testify um and get back down if need be
and with that representative uh thank
you very much Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
Maguire I represent the town of
Epsom um I'm happy to co-sponsor this
bill because I see it as just sort of um
basic sort of
antitrust legislation for the labor
Arena so let me give you an example
suppose in the in the regular business
Arena um apple and Verizon were to get
together and make an agreement such that
Verizon would exclusively sell iPhones
to their customers and there wouldn't
allow any customer uh new to come in
with with a non with some other kind of
phone only iPhones right well that
agreement that might benefit Apple it
might benefit
Verizon but it would not benefit the
public right that that would be um a
monopolistic agreement and if if if they
tried to make such an agreement um the
justice department antitrust division
would have something to say to them
so in the Labor Field what we're talking
about here is is something very similar
right suppose uh the AFL CIO and Walmart
got together and they said uh okay
everybody who works for Walmart has to
belong to the AFL CIO and we won't hire
anyone else all right that might work
well for the aflcio it possibly could
even work well for Walmart but it's not
right for the public
right because
because if the people being working and
being paid and Walmart are all
gaining it's the consumers who are
losing right so um and our constitution
is very clear about this right it has
very strong anti-m monopolistic language
in part two article 83 so I I see this
very simply I I don't see that those two
examples the commercial example and the
labor example have any real difference
chairman thank you very much for your
questions I have so much respect for you
representative a soft spot in my heart
for you um we do disagree on this one um
would you believe that mit's business
school professors at mit's business
school have multiple studies that show
when workers are either organized or
treated very well paid decent wage that
those companies like Costco for example
are um not when they're happier and when
they're treated well they actually uh
are more profitable compared to to
companies like
Walmart so um would you believe that
even at mit's business school um the
value of
Labor has been expressed in a different
way than um you
mentioned um thanks for the question if
it is a question I guess
uh you know I I'll take your word for it
um but I don't think it's quite relevant
to to what I was uh talking
about further
questions representative
stop thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm a little confused about
something you said you said if the
workers at Walmart were um were members
of a union that they would benefit but
that members of the public and consumers
would lose my question to you is are
people that work at Walmart also members
of the public and um
consumers thank you for the question of
course they are yeah but but they're not
all consumers right there there are
some um so so so I mean if you read part
two article 83 right it it talks very
clearly about monopolies and and
combinations and exclusivity and things
like that that's what's going
on further question representative
McKenzie representative MCU thank you
for hearing before the
committee your logic um seems to ignore
the fact that there is a separate
structure that governs Labor
Relations uh it's not the antitrust law
it's not business law it's the National
Labor Relations
law so in that context have you ever
reviewed the National Labor Relations
law and are you familiar with the the
terms and conditions under which people
work yes thanks for the question I the
the basic answer is no I'm not an
attorney I'm an engineer okay but I
think my logic is sound all right I
don't think um there's a substantive
difference uh between uh paying for
labor and paying for
follow
up uh the person before you um suggested
or said that people are compelled to be
members of any Union uh are you are you
familiar uh with the way that this thing
works in terms of compelling anybody uh
and the prohibition against compelling
somebody to be in a
union um I I think so not uh not super
well I mean I I personally had a working
career I was never a member of a union
um but um as I understand it you can be
compelled to
pay uh at least some portion of dues but
you don't have you're not compelled to
be a
member technically in the sense that you
you join and vote and things like that
that's the way I understand it but I
could I could easily be
wrong final final question are you
familiar with CWA versus
Beck no which prohibits uh uh compelling
people to pay even a uh even at agency
fee you familiar you're not familiar
with that no okay thank
you further questions from the committee
Clair yes turn the mic on because people
upstairs can't appreciate it
representative mire I just wanted to ask
you the same question I asked
representative poz of if you have the
choice right you can you know if you
don't want to go to Verizon because
their Union you don't go to whomever
else Comcast whomever else whatever
carry anywhere don't you think that's
all right thank you for the question so
obviously there's um there are edge
cases right I mean
things the the justice department
doesn't go after people who are this big
they go after people who are this big
right um you could say the same right
now for example they're suing Google for
having deals with computer manufacturers
that makes their search engine the
default search engine they pay they pay
manufacturers to do that well you could
say the exact same argument you could
say well they can use Bing or they can
use this other search engine right so so
therefore there's nothing wrong
well the justice department thinks there
is something wrong okay and and let me
again let me if you mind don't mind Mr
chairman I I just want to respond to
some of these questions you're thinking
of this this bill and this situation as
just having two parties involved right
the employer and the employee and that's
it but the point of my testimony is
there's a third person in this room and
that's the rest of the public and that's
who who um whose condition we we should
be thinking about thank you Mr chair
thank you uh representative Bui thank
you Mr chairman I wasn't going to ask
you any questions my friend but what you
just said there's three people involved
the employer the
employee but the person in the middle is
what this is all about the person in the
middle is going to be responsible for
negotiating in for this employee taking
care of him when he's in trouble and he
is the the injured party let's say if
this bill passes because he won't be
able to get compensated for the work
they do thank you
do is there a would you believe in that
would you believe would you have a
response to that no I disagree but
anyways any further
questions thank you very much
so um next up is Rich Gula representing
the sea in opposition to the bill um
after that Maggie Fogerty and
representative Ellen Reid and I have
been asked to speak to the chairman so
I'm going to go out and take that call
and I'll ask uh representative avalani
to lead this testimony yes that goes to
you thank you Mr G go ahead uh good
afternoon uh thank you Mr chairman
honorable members M of the committee my
name is Richard gulla I am president of
the state employees Association of New
Hampshire represent approximately 10,000
employees State County Municipal private
sector and law enforcement uh I'll be
brief uh this is I believe my 10th time
uh testifying in front of this honorable
committee on this matter uh I have
submitted testimony over the past 10
years on this so uh you're you're free
to reference that and seek me out for
any questions I I I truly believe if um
if we want to attract and retain
employees in in this current environment
that we should be looking at ways to um
encourage our communities and
municipalities to build affordable
worker housing we are are short of
worker housing in the state of New
Hampshire no business is going to want
to do business in New Hampshire they if
they uh if the employees can't find a
place to live and uh with that I'll
conclude my testimony thank you thank
you Mr G any questions for
this
representative
stop um thank you for taking my question
I'm not sure if you're the person um who
can answer this question but maybe um
somebody else that comes after you can
um I would like to know what the impact
on wages up and down the line are in
Right to Work versus non-right to work
states I just did a quick online search
and I found that of the 10 states with
the highest poverty rate six of them
were to work
states that is correct it's my
understanding as well um right to work
states the standard of living is much
less than in states where unions prosper
and
Thrive thank you any further
questions thank you for taking my
question uh you mentioned that uh you a
private sector a public sector Union uh
since the Jan's decision has Union you
union membership gone
down um it did a little but it's bounced
back up thank
you thank you any further
questions thank you Mr SCA thank you uh
Fogerty uh rep Ellen Reed is next and
bracket and you have testimony I do yes
thank you I'll submit that thank you a
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Maggie Fogerty I'm here
wearing multiple hats I am the New
Hampshire program director for the
American friend service committee an
organization dedicated throughout its
106 years and counting uh to the rights
and well-being of workers I'm here as a
proud 16-year Union member Unite Here
Local
66l and I'm here as a Quaker and a
member of a growing group of New
Hampshire people of Faith called New
Hampshire Voices of Faith and it's on
their behalf that I give testimony today
1377 the members of New Hampshire Voices
of Faith come together from multiple
Faith Traditions throughout the state to
bring a moral witness to issues of
justice and equity in our state in our
policymaking so as a matter of
conscience we bear faithful witness to
the need for policies that promote
well-being that promote equality
especially among those of us who are
most vulnerable and whose rights and
dignity are under attack so one bill
that is causing a significant concern is
the return yet again of a so-called
Right to Work bill in this case HB
1377 it is not in the interest of New
Hampshire people and we urge you to
recommend
itl we recognize that the phrase Right
to Work can fool anyone including us
because it certainly sounds good the
disturbing reality however is that this
policy is not about providing access to
work for anyone but it's designed
specifically to weaken unions and to
weaken workers capacity for Collective
action that's it it was first dreamed up
in the 1940s in the Jim Crow South as a
calculated effort to uphold the racial
divide among workers by creating a
mechanism for white workers to avoid
being part of unions or paying dues to a
union that included black
workers the Dual Focus was maintaining
racial Division and dramatically
weakening emerging and existing unions
both of which are very much counter to
our shared moral
values despite protestations to the
contrary worker division plus the
undermining of unions and collective
bargaining Remains the key purpose of
1377 I want to add that the push for
this bill is not bubbling up from New
Hampshire people it's the product of
well-healed outof State groups who have
spent Untold sums to Pedal this bill in
New Hampshire year or session after
session you as a legislator are the
target of these advocacy
groups the proponents of this bill claim
that new employers will flock to the
state of this bill is passed but they
cannot cite a single example of any such
employer waiting in the wings for us to
become a right to work
state in order to arrive here and HB
1377 targets private sector workplaces
where unions exist it actually prohibits
an employer from agreeing to certain
unifying language in the collective
collectively bargained contract with
workers New Hampshire employers have not
asked for this in fact just the opposite
numerous New Hampshire employers have
pleaded with the legislature do not
interfere with our freedom to decide for
ourselves how to work with our
unions one major New Hampshire employer
said that this testimony would be a
burdensome and costly intrusion on our
freedom as a privately held
business at its core this runs contrary
to New Hampshire's Live Free or Die
principles by inserting state government
into private business
Affairs so Faith leaders across the
state are clear in our opposition to
this bill and we thank you for your
attention to this testimony and we urge
you to defeat it thank
you thank you any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you can you
pass that forward to the Clark thank
next
thank you once again honorable members
of the committee um I the only reason I
am speaking to you on this particular
bill because otherwise I wouldn't have
more to add is because I have a very
unique story um that I want to share
with you for the record my name is Ellen
Reed and I represent new fields and New
Market um I do want to correct a few
things that were said uh and for the
record I am very very opposed to this
bill um so once again no one no one
forces anyone to pay membership dues
that is not what we are talking about
the Free Rider fee that goes by other
names but I call it a free rider fee is
something that is negotiated freely and
agreed to by the employer um and it
covers a whole bunch of services as you
already know and that's what the kind of
Crux of my story will center around and
um it is federal law nothing we can do
in New Hampshire can stop the fact that
a union does have to provide those
services to all people in that
bargaining unit we cannot change the
structure as I think the the prime
sponsor had
said um that fee is very very minimal uh
even a membership dues is very minimal
compared to the increase in pay that
unions get when they um bargain for
their contracts which is why union jobs
are famously better jobs um and not only
is that a small free writer fee minimal
but none of it and I I've heard this in
years past when we've dealt with right
to work um that somehow those that that
those dues or the free writer fees go to
political purposes that is illegal um
none of it goes to political purposes
and also I heard from the prime sponsor
I believe that states that had already
passed um right to work had uh reduced
uh unemployment I grew up in one of
those States I grew up in Tennessee
until I was 23 actually um I didn't even
know what a a labor union was um and I
can't speak to the unemployment side but
I can speak to like maybe it would be
lower unemployment because people are
forced into working multiple jobs
because the pay in those States is so
atrocious if you look at the economy of
Tennessee and compare it to New
Hampshire I guarantee you you wouldn't
change um their economic situation with
our
um it is a I grew up in a very
economically depressed
state so my particular story is when I
got elected I decided to leave kind of
the professional advocacy world and go
back to CDL driving um and the place
that I worked in addition to being the
lowest paid um company in the entire
State we got new management and the
management was pretty severe started uh
working us really crazy hours crazy
split shifts taking away our ability to
go to doctor's appointments and things
like that so I decided to start
unionizing and uh did you know
management doesn't like it when you do
that um very quickly when it was found
out that I was unionizing um much
against our discipline policy which
required warnings and what have you I
was immediately suspended for 5 days
without pay for not tucking in my
shirt um there were a few other
incidents like that I kept getting kind
of slapped down and then finally they
put me on a fully paid administrative
leave pending an investigation the
charges for which I still to this day I
don't know I was not working but
receiving my full salary for a month
before and there's here's where the free
riter fee comes in uh the union lawyers
sent a cease and desist letter to the
employer they were there with me every
time I met with the employer or the
employer's lawyers they stood by my side
and I hadn't even successfully gotten
that year
Union I can't name a single worker who
doesn't appreciate having backup when
you go against your employer who's
treating you
unfairly and that is what the free riter
fee that is freely negotiated between
two private uh entities pays for and has
to pay for by
law unions are democracy in the
workplace without unions your workplace
is an authoritarian regime the boss has
all the control and workers have nothing
unions are what allow employees to come
together and negotiate together so that
they can balance out that force of power
if you believe in the decentralization
of power if you are against
authoritarianism then you should believe
in
unions the idea that unions are a
monopoly I find to be absurd first of
all there is no one Union that's
claiming all of the the labor market but
it simply levels that playing field and
what I I think that's why employers are
mad about it is because it does level
the playing field and they don't like it
so with that um I don't think that I can
answer any more questions if someone
really has a burning question I'm happy
to answer it but I just wanted to share
my personal story thank you very much
and uh I apologize for walking out
um I don't know whether that went over
three minutes but I'll again remind
everybody to please uh limit your
testimony and um please if you hear
something that you were going to say um
maybe you don't need to repeat it the
reason this is on my mind is I uh had a
conversation with the chairman and he
got a call from
security uh wondering about how long
we're going to keep them over um at some
point we may have to uh hold the hearing
and put uh continue the hearing to
another time that was the suggestion I
got from a chair the chairman hopefully
uh we won't need to do that it looks
like the representative has somewhere to
be so rather than go to questions I'll
call up the next speaker which is Glenn
bracket the president of the AFL
CIO and following him will be Tyler Le
plant and Janice Kell Kel I probably got
that wrong and I apologize for names I
got wrong earlier so with that
uh please well thank you very much Mr
chairman I appreciate the professional
courtesy thank you very much uh for the
record my name is Glenn bracket and I'll
be exceedingly brief as there's a lot of
people to speak uh Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is
Glenn bracket I'm the president of the
New Hampshire AFL CIO and a 45-year
member of the International Brotherhood
of Electrical Workers my organization
represents over 50 Affiliated local
labor unions in New Hampshire and
approximately 50,000 workers across this
state our membership includes nurses
First Responders Firefighters truck
drivers law enforcement postal workers
teachers in the unions of the New
Hampshire Building Trades and their
privately funded Apprentice
programs I come I come before you today
on behalf of these New Hampshire workers
to oppose House Bill
1377 which is the house version of this
session's fraud titled right to work now
every new legislative session for the
last 35 years has seen this attack on
workers rights and every legislation
every legislature regardless of which
party is in the majority has rejected it
in fact in 2021 in 2019 this house
rejected this very same bill Governor
sonunu himself declared that there is no
need to pursue any additional
legislation when it comes to right to
work our elective leaders have
repeatedly defeated this piece of
legislation because they understand that
the free market does not need any
further government intrusion or
regulatory burdens into the private
business World a lot of State
billionaires and DC lobbyists continue
to enlist legislators to introduce
identical bills year in and year out our
elected representatives of both
political parties have voted to defeat
them that is because it's clear that New
Hampshire's government should not meddle
in how private businesses in this state
do business with other parties for their
Mutual benefit contracts between private
employers and labor units are businesso
business agreements that this
legislature should leave to the free
market supporters of Right to Work claim
that it will hurt people from being
forced into joining labor unions and
this bill will advance freedom of
Association in truth this is a non-issue
since the passing of the the TA heartley
act in 1947 it is illegal to force
workers to become part of a union this
Freedom of Choice already exists for New
Hampshire workers this bill will
diminish Freedom it will diminish the
American Spirit of free enterprise and
contracts by allowing the state the
government to interfere with businesso
business exchanges through this
government intervention the state would
be creating a Free Rider by providing
benefits to those who don't pay for them
it diminishes the freedom of workers to
join together in the workplace to help
provide for their families it is
difficult for me to think of another
circumstance that the sponsors of this
bill would agree with where the
government would require a private
business with a contract with another
private business to provide free service
to involve itself in negotiations
between two private entities or to
advocate for the expansion of government
at taxpayers expense it is for these
reasons and many more that you will here
today that I respectfully request this
honorable committee vote itl on House
Bill
1377 thank you very much thank you and
if that testimony can be turned to the
clerk thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you again
for your testimony um so next up I'll
call Tyler l plant representing I a TS
e481 and following uh that testimony
will be Janice kelba and Kristen go
went
IAT it's II I just have horrible
that never know whether to sound out
acronyms or say no it's all good either
way works um good afternoon my name is
Tyler llant I'm from nashille New
Hampshire and I'm a proud union worker
I'm a part of the International Alliance
of theatrical stage employees local 481
which means I work on film and
television projects in the New England
area workers in my industry are highly
skilled and professional individuals and
that's thanks to the strength of our
Union House Bill 1377 FN and Senate Bill
516 FN I know we're not talking about
that one seeks to St seeks to take the
strength out of New Hampshire's workers
hands and give that power back to
outside big businesses who are only
interested in higher profit margins now
in order to make those higher profit Mar
margins businesses unless the help of
Republicans to dra to draft these quote
Right to Work
bills these bills are deceptively made
out to seem as though they are in the
interest of New Hampshire workers by
giving legal bypasses to joining unions
in reality these bills take away better
health benefits better pay and
negotiation rights apart from these
pitfalls another major concern to this
bill is the safety of the of the New
Hampshire worker unions provide free
required trainings for members as well
as higher safety standards across the
board now let's say these bills pass I
mean hopefully not but just for the sake
of the argument let's say they do uh
what do the workers get out of this I
mean sure they won't have to join a
union if they don't want to but they
also wouldn't be making as much as their
Union Brothers they wouldn't be having a
pension or access to Affordable Health
Care I think it's time that we refer to
these so-called Right to Work bills as
what they really are union busting scab
work promoting garbage New Hampshire
Republicans are not creating these bills
in the interest of the people it's in
the interest of the big companies and
anti-labor lobbyists who line their
pockets every election season unions
make workers strong workers make New
Hampshire strong thank you and
solidarity
forever thank you for your testimony any
questions
seeing none thank you again all right uh
so I would Now call Janice K Kelo kby
Kelby thank you make me nervous
represent representing herself um in
opposition and coming up next Kristen
Goen and John
drinkwater good afternoon my name is
Janice Kelby and I appreciate the
opportunity to testify in opposition to
HB 13 77 I'm a retired postal worker I
joined the union immediately after I was
hired and worked a midnight shift in a
maale processing plant for the US Postal
Service for 29 years I live in hookset
New Hampshire as a single parent when I
was hired I knew that the benefits that
made me want the job at the post office
had been obtained through negotiations
with the Union it's probably more
evident with the Postal Service than it
is in other workplaces
because the Postal Service had a
category of employees called casuals
casuals were not necessarily short-term
employees some had worked there for over
10 years they were not a part of any
bargaining unit and could not belong to
a
union this made the difference very
obvious between what the Postal Service
gave to employees out of the kindness of
their heart and what was negotiated by
the union it was crystal clear to me
that the union was responsible for
making the job a desirable one casual
wages were far less than ours even
though they often did identical work
they got no sick leave no health
benefits they earned minimal paid time
off and no retirement benefits folks
were not knocking down the doors for
these casual positions but they were for
the career
positions um complete with the benefits
negotiated by the union any worker who
tells you they want nothing to do with
the Union is not telling you the entire
truth they do want the benefits that
have been achieved by the union and
those benefits do not just fall out of
the sky sadly working in a USPS is like
working in a right to work state in some
ways people who choose not to join a
union don't share the cost of
representation most postal workers do
join the union but not all having some
people enjoy contract benefits without
helping to pay for them causes Division
and
resentment in the workplace and that
division neither benefits the workers or
the employer or productivity for that
matter this paper doesn't want to
cooperate with me the union is obligated
by law to represent these non-members
who pay nothing not even for their own
personal
representation I remember my local
defending a non-member and arbitration
18 years ago that cost was more than
$1,500 for just one day of hearing our
cost not his the bigger issue is the
considerable resources that go into that
are required to negotiate our contract I
once was asked to testify at a national
hearing that involved the pay wage for a
specific job and I listen to the
testimony from economics econom ists and
a host of experts and as well as Rank
and file workers listening to The
Economist I wondered how many hours of
research and preparation went into her
testimony the union paid for that work
without her testimony we would never
have convinced the arbitrator to upgrade
to pay for that job even the guy who
chose not to pay his fair share real
people have a real right to work right
now in New Hampshire we have a right to
choose to work in a union shop or to
choose a non-union shop even in Union
workplaces not all Union workplaces have
a fair share Clause employers have to
agree if an employer negotiates fair
share as a condition of employment the
state has no business
interfering just as it has no business
interfering with a dress code policy if
a person doesn't like a company's fair
share policy employment policy or
doesn't like a dress code there are
other places they can
work and of course they are free to talk
to their co-workers as well and if they
can convince them that it's a bad
condition at their workplace they can
negotiate it out in the next contract my
union struggles to meet the financial
burden caused by those who refuse to pay
their fair share if enough people
decided not to do their part then the
union would be seriously weakened which
is the whole purpose of this law
lessening our ability to negotiate
decent wages and benefits it would have
a negative impact on our state without
benefits negotiated by my union I
couldn't afford a house and I couldn't
afford to support local New Hampshire
businesses as I do now safety in the
workplace would also be very negatively
impacted it was the union that waged a
major safety campaign literally saving
the lives of postal workers I remember
well the death of New York postal worker
Michael mcder who was pulled into a
conveyor belt and lost his life I'm
forever grateful for the resources that
our Union was able to put into waging
the battle to increase the worker safety
and all who benefit should share in the
cost HP
1377 does nothing to expand anyone's
right to work it serves only to weaken
unions lower our standard of living and
hurt New Hampshire's economy the state
should did not interfere with collective
bargaining and with the employer's
decision to negotiate an employment
policy that requires workers to pay
their fair share for services that they
enjoy I ask that you vote inexpedient to
leg to legislate on
HB
1377 thank you thank you for your
testimony and if you're able to willing
to turn that into the clerk we
appreciate it are there any
questions okay just hand it to yeah yeah
yeah you can okay hand it to somebody in
the end we'll pass
around um seeing no questions uh next I
would call Kristen Goen of the national
electrical contractors
Association and coming up after John
Shapiro and did I get your name wrong go
in okay go in gow in it's all the same
uh thank you very much Mr chairman and
honorable committee members my name is
Kristen Gowan and I the manager of the
electrical contractors Association
representing nearly 200 electrical
contractors in the state of New
Hampshire also covering Maine and
Massachusetts I come before the
committee today to voice NAA and our
contractor's opposition to House Bill
1377 also known as the right to work NAA
is responsible for bringing light power
Communications to building Comm
communities vertical horizontal
construction across the United States we
have 119 chapters throughout the
country we represent the contractors
when it comes to Labor Relations most
important so at the collective
bargaining table negotiating with our
ibw partners but also advocacy education
research safety and standard development
we are only able to accomplish this as
Union employers through our partnership
ship and collaboration with the ibw the
International Brotherhood of Electrical
Workers this partnership with the ibw
allows us to perform work with special
knowledge and experience needed for
every kind of electrical and
Telecommunications
project it allows us to reduce the
accidents reduce the injuries and in
turn reduce costly delays on
construction projects our partnership
with the ibw also allows us to eliminate
callbacks it limits change
orders which helps avoid emergencies
that can bust budgets or incidents that
turn into legal issues when a contractor
calls the hiring Hall the ibw they know
that they are going to get someone who
is trained highly skilled and
knowledgeable the training of these
workers is done most important with zero
expense to the taxpayer the na
contractors that are voluntarily Union
contractors attract electricians and
technicians from outside the Union as
well as generations of new career
Seekers looking to invest themselves in
model we do all this and we can do this
work because of the agreements that we
have made privately in the private
sector with the IBEW and its membership
both the ibw members and the contractors
that I represent provide value to one
another the electricians rece reive
training Fair pay safe working
conditions while the contractors in turn
receive the highly trained and skilled
Workforce that meet these requirements
and obligations on projects once again
zero cost to the public this is a
business model much like some of the
other organizations the apples Walmart
those are business models this has been
our business model for decades and we do
not need the government to interfere
with the contracts and the agreements
that we privately
negotiate
and that we have as PRI A Private
Business
Association this relationship is
essential not only to our continued
success in the construction industry but
also to the continued success of the
infrastructure projects across New
Hampshire and throughout the country
although most of our na contractors are
small business owners we also represent
the large business owners that probably
work throughout all these states that I
mentioned above all of these businesses
think that the right to work is bad for
business and on behalf of these
businesses and on behalf of all the NAA
contractors we respectfully oppose this
bill and would request that you do the
same thank you and if the copy can be
provided that would be great are there
any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony okay thank you um next up I
will call John drinkwater and I'm going
to try your suggestion do I say this iup
pet
DC35 or do I yes okay and coming up
after that Lisa Shapiro and Greg Moore
will speak thank you Mr chairman there
is um one other colleague here from
iupat DC35 would you like us to to come
up together that would be fine if you
that thank you um thank you Mr chairman
and um honorable members of the
committee excuse me my name is John
drink Squad I'm the director of
government Affairs for iupat DC35 I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today and I want to say from our
perspective we're we're a union that
represents over 4,000 workers in the
finishing trades in Massachusetts New
Hampshire Main and Vermont and uh along
with representing workers in the
construction trades we also represent
public sector workers so we understand
um to what it's like um in a right to
work environment in the public sector
since the Janice rule ruling now I'm
happy to say that 100% of our workers in
the public sector have chosen to join
our Union because they recognize that we
represent them and we provide a pretty
good deal when it comes to
representation and I do find it
interesting when it comes to regulating
employer um employee and labor union
relationships that our duty the duty
that we have to represent each and every
worker under our Collective bargain
agreements whether or not they choice to
Jo CH choose to join our Union is not
something that is often regulated it's
the financial agreement between unions
and employers that are privately
negotiated and part of a a contract that
tends to be the thing that's regulated
and I think that's because most would
recognize that workers get a pretty good
deal when they're covered by a Union
contract and the representation that
they receive if they file a meritorious
grievance their Union is obligated to
pursue that on their behalf and and we
we think that's a good thing we want to
represent each and every worker that
falls under our contract but it's also
Fair uh that that those workers um pay
uh for the cost of their representation
that's provided by the union and that's
why uh we understand Right to Work bills
to be something that are just to attack
Union finances and make it difficult to
do what we do now when unions can worry
about more than just trying to collect
enough fees to provide the
representation that we're obligated to
we can go out and do things like
organized we can go out and talk to
members of the community about the value
of what a union apprenticeship provides
and that's what members of our staff do
we provide training and career
opportunities and we try to extend those
to those who may not have uh a foot in
the door to unions and when we can think
about more than just surviving and
collecting enough fees to do what it is
that we have to do we can go out there
and reach out to the community to
Residents in new Hamp ampire and talk
about the great value and the great
opportunities that a union career can
provide and we just simply ask that we
can continue doing that for the
residence of New Hampshire thank you
thank you for your testimony and did you
fill out a separate card um we should
have all been on the same card oh it was
all on the same card okay thank you
you're welcome we're good um hi my name
is Phil Blair I'm a resident taxpayer in
the state of New Hampshire I'm a member
of cc35 painters and Alli trades I'm
also the vice president of New Hampshire
Building Trades um I've been involved
with organized labor for 23 years being
part of a union and always knowing that
a union has my back and Bargains on my
behalf for all the great wages and
benefits that I receive for myself and
my family is the greatest feeling to
have knowing that I can retire at a
decent age is what I strive for every
worker already has the right to either
join a union or not the New Hampshire
motto is Live Free or Die being in a
union and paying union dues for the
union to collectively bargain on your
behalf it's no different than any other
membership fee you would have to pay at
a golf course gy Costco BJs Etc or the
Chamber of Commerce and I quote to get
started complete your application and we
will collect your $25 application fee
once we review your application we will
invoice you for your membership dues and
we are often running right to work
actually has nothing to do with work of
freedom and everything with to do with
breaking organized labor and
strengthening corporate control of a
politics workers have very little
bargaining power in the United States
and in most developed countries workers
have more say and uh better working
conditions in America unless you're in a
union workplace Dynamic gives all the
power to the owner if businesses and
interests are not checked by the
bargaining power of labor unions and
other worker groups then we will quickly
become a developing country the safest
most trained and skilled labor is that
of union labor we fight every day not
just for union labor but for labor in
general this so-called Right to Work
bill is nothing as it reads is a right
to work for Less study shows that
workers in right to work states make
$10,000 less a year while the CEOs get
320 times richer off the back of the
workers unions make up unions make up 7%
of the workforce in this country in the
construction field 4% this country was
built on union labor it's because of
organized labor and the right to
collectively bargain is why we have
eight hour work days 5day work weeks and
40 hour work week six leave Etc this is
why we have the safest workers in work
sites going today and this is all
factual
information working people in right to
work states have consistently lower
quality of life when compared to right
to work states to free bargaining States
and the differences are not comparable
they have less access to health care and
poor education systems for children the
poverty rate is higher and the risk of
workplace fatalities is 49% higher when
working people can't freely speak up
together they can't negotiate for higher
safety standards better training Fair
wages and health benefits and this will
all and that will impact all of us Union
and non-union alike right to work will
lower wages cause higher workplace
injuries and increase poverty will this
make our state more attractive I don't
think so I urge you to vote no on House
Bill
1377 right to work is wrong for New
Hampshire thank you any questions seeing
question
turn on your
microphone the the uh trades model is
somewhat different than it than the
others uh other workplaces might be so a
member comes in to the painters comes
into the uh uh the the plumbers and pipe
fitters um they become a union member um
right off the bat
so is there any time that um that those
workers um are not Union or how do you
handle when somebody does not want to be
in the Union in the Building Trades and
I ask you this because this has come up
in the discussions here
before you understand my understand the
question I do and the the building TRS a
little different So within within our
jurisdiction that we cover with DC 35 um
we don't um operate in a right to work
environment in in the private sector um
so the agreements that do we have with
our signatory contractors do include uh
Union security Clauses uh where those um
you know either dues or fees are are
collected uh from from our members as as
part of the agreement between
DC35 and signatory contractors um where
we we do operate as I had mentioned uh
in in my remarks in in a right to work
environment is in the public sector uh
in in each of the states that we
represent so we do understand how that
works differently um in the different
sectors that we represent and that's
been been a fairly new thing for us as a
result of the the jna Supreme Court case
so how how that is operated um generally
in the public sector our employees come
to us through their public sector
employer rather than through a training
program or through a signatory employer
um and in that case we we've operated
just like the rest of the public sector
and we've had to to educate uh members
of our own Union on the The Importance
uh that provides and essentially every
single one of those members has had to
um be signed again um signed for a
second time as a member of the Union
we've had a lot of great success in
doing that but the trades are a little
bit different and that many people come
to us uh with an application in hand uh
for the the training that we provide
jointly with our employers um so when
when we get those applications people
are approaching us desperately want
wanting to be a member uh of the Union
because not just for the representation
that we provide but for the the skills
uh that they get through in
apprenticeship program so the model is a
little bit different in that people see
the value that that they're getting
before they ever walk onto a job site or
into a training center great thank you
thank you for the question represent be
proud of Youk you any further
questions all right thank you um next up
I would call Lisa Shapiro uh
representing New Hampshire AFL CIO and
following her Greg Moore and John buo oh
sorry oh thank you uh good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Dr Lisa shapy I'm Chief
Economist at Gallagher Calahan gartell
and conquered New Hampshire and I'm here
today on behalf of the AFL CIO in
opposition to HB 1377
from an economic perspective you'll hear
from right to work Advocates asserting
that right to work states outperform
non-right to work states and it would
therefore be beneficial to the New
Hampshire economy if Right to Work were
passed and further the passing right to
work enhances economic freedom these
arguments should be rejected on several
grounds first the best science the
articles that are published in peer
reviewed journals not just public policy
shops attached and working for Advocates
find in these published studies that
right to work states end up with lower
wage growth for example a
2019 article in the Journal of financial
economics reviewed nearly 20,000
collective bargaining agreements over a
period of time in States before they
pass right to work after they pass right
to work and found that in those right to
work states there was a decrease in
workers wage growth and an increase in
executive compensation in
2023 Federal Reserve researchers closely
analyze wages in six states that adopted
right to work over the last 20 years in
particular Oklahoma Indiana Michigan
Wisconsin West Virginia and Kentucky and
they can be compared the conditions
before and after passing right to work
and with States that had not adopted
right to work and in response to
adoption of these laws here in this case
they did find a slight uptick in
employment you'd expect that there are
some businesses that want to work and be
located where there is less Union
involvement however while this was very
small they did find an actual ual annual
uh reduction in real wages of
$1900 so after right to work was in real
wages went down while some right to work
states clearly are doing well simply
comparing right to work states with free
bargaining States across a range of
metrics doesn't tell us whether right to
work is economically beneficial there
are competing explanations for why any
individual State performs well factors
including electric rates which is a big
dri in manufacturing location business
taxes business incentives and a
regulatory climate may have a stronger
effect on economic performance than
right to work laws studies that claim
that right to work helps economic growth
tend to be selective in their analysis
of which states or counties to incl
include what time period what metric how
to model it and whether other
explanatory factors are even considered
and what approach they use to doing this
have not been uh held up in the
peer-reviewed
literature third as a matter of
principle right to work is government
intervention in private contracts we
just heard about that directly which
reduces economic freedom Milton Freedman
a well-known Economist who advocated for
free market capitalism and other
prominent libertarian thinkers although
in the minority have been consistently
against right to work laws why because
right to work laws limit and restrict
workers and employers freedom of
contract they substitute the decision of
politicians for the players in the
marketplace
now while the KO Institute out of
Washington advocates for right to work
laws in for New Hampshire recently came
out as number one in Freedom you may
have heard that it was touted by many in
the state so you look into that report
and right to work is an aspect they
think that's a good thing but somehow we
still managed to come out as number one
in
Freedom furthermore in the report it
admits quote right to work laws are
controversial among Libertarians and in
fact it provides an alternative Freedom
index in the back of the report which
excludes right to work laws for those
Libertarians that don't agree with right
to work laws as being a measure of
Freedom finally economic growth and
well-being currently New Hampshire's
economy generally ranks well compared to
other states across a range of economic
metrics including lower unemployment
rates lower poverty rates higher median
wages New Hampshire's economic headwinds
for growth probably revolve more around
access to affordable housing and child
care and getting young people into
careers where there are jobs that they
are needed for on a range of metrics new
excuse me New Hampshire outperforms
right to work states please vote itl on
HB 1377 keep the New Hampshire
government from intervening in these
relationships HB 1377 puts at risk
workers opportunities for training
working and making a good living and the
employers who want to work with them
thank you thank you for your testimony
um the testimony is going well over the
three minutes I don't want to have to
cut people off so especially if you have
a long lengthy written testimony please
try to summarize rather than uh go
through it thank you um if you can turn
that into the clerk I'm sure we'd
appreciate it and are there any
questions are you sure okay
representative love thank you for taking
my question uh you mentioned government
intervention in in the employer employee
relationship quite a few times and uh
since uh Taft hotley and maybe before
hasn't the government been sticking its
nose in the employee employer
relationship yes the government the
federal government is quite involved
this what this is here is a New
Hampshire law
intervention and many economists do not
buy into the concept that if one thing
is bad do another thing that's just as
bad and somehow that's going to make it
better so even for those that are
opposed to any involvement in unions the
intervention uh representative
Granger uh thank you for taking my
question uh do you oppose government
intervention in the economy
generally the government represents
about 20% of the economy so uh there's
an awful lot of uh tentacles of the
government involved in the economy and I
think each and every decision that comes
before you as a committee other
committees in New Hampshire you have to
look at what is in front of us and in
1377 it is a new intervention into the
economy okay thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
for your testimony uh next up I would
ask Greg Moore representing Americans
for Prosperity to speak and coming after
him John buap pen I messed it up again
didn't I and uh DJ
Blan thank you Mr chair Mr Vice chair
members of the committee I appreciate
the opportunity to to join you today for
the record my name is Greg Moore I'm a
regional director for Americans for
Prosperity here today to testify in
support of house bill
1377 uh this is not a novel issue as
many speakers have mentioned before this
is a mature issue uh certainly got on my
radar screen when I was uh working in
for the N Hampshire house first as a
policy director then the chief of staff
uh this legislation has passed the house
a couple times passed the Senate a
couple times passed the house and the
Senate once uh didn't quite make it
through the governor's VTO but it's it's
an issue that's going to continue
continue to be discussed and it should
be continue discussed I I think if we go
back and look at the history in 1935 the
Wagner Act took place uh that now is
known as the National Labor Relations
Act prior to that that uh in many
workforces there were multiple unions uh
who had members uh and there were in a
non-union me Members would bargain for
themselves the uh National Labor
Relations Act brought in a provision of
exclusive representation that provision
meant that if one Union could get 50%
plus one members of of of that that
Workforce to agree to join then no other
Union could participate and that on that
on that that bargaining unit as well as
the fact that uh non- non-union members
lost their right to negotiate for
themselves seeing a little bit of a of a
uh over correction in 1947 the Taft
heartley uh Taft heartley act otherwise
known as the Labor Management Relations
Act was passed that authorized these
right to work laws across States
ultimately uh ultimately 26 States now
are right to work states out of the 50
in the union I will just offer a few bit
of anecdotes because you guys are going
to get tons of data throwing at you on
this issue and I don't want to just
continue to just throw more stuff into a
wall but I'll I'll tell you some
experiences that I've had first and
foremost I was uh working at the
Department of Health and Human Services
in 2005 when they implemented an agency
fee so I saw I saw the amount of rancor
that that brought in the my my
co-workers I was I was not actually not
eligible to join a union but uh but a
number of my my colleagues who were
non-members were very upset by this as
you can imagine money was going to be
deducted from their paycheck ultimately
that was reversed in 2018 with the the
uh the Janice decision and obviously no
non-union members now have to pay pay a
due I'll also talk on behalf a little
bit of of some of our activists and that
hopefully that'll explain why some
employers support Right to Work
legislation uh one of our activists uh
he was part of a union shop and uh he
felt as though the union was not
necessarily bargaining on his behalf he
felt there were a lot of senior members
that they were bargain on behalf of the
senior members he was he was a junior
member he he wanted different things out
of the negotiations and he didn't get it
well he didn't want to continue to pay a
union that he felt is working against
his best interests so this notion that
that somehow all all people are
benefiting by the bargaining of the
Union I I think that's overblown and I
think that there are real life examples
of that it is true it is true that uh
that if you are part of a Union contract
the union must represent you that is
true all all people in the bargaining
are represented by the contract but I'll
tell you one anecdote back in 2011 when
we passed the uh Right to Work
legislation in the house and what
happened in that instance is that
argument was raised and this committee
the house labor committee actually put a
provision in that said that public
sector unions did not have to represent
repr represent all employees in the in
the in the bargaining unit when that
bill went over the wall to the Senate
and that public hearing came up the
first thing that the unions attacked was
the fact that they didn't get a chance
to represent all members so with that
I'm probably at three minutes and I
don't want to take any more of this
committee's time so I I'll stop there
and take any questions all right thank
you uh any questions yes go ahead thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking the
question so you obviously know there's a
lot of businesses and associations in
the state that charge will have members
that they charge fees to represent them
so why would we discriminate against a
company just because it has a union logo
on it see I I sponsor want a
clarification are you talking about
customers I'm talking about businesses
as a lobbyist I'm sure you have clients
you have members and I'm sure you don't
do it for free I'm assuming that you get
paid to represent members so my the
question is why would we discriminate
against a union company to allow it not
to represent its members and get paid
for it well if if thank you for the
question if the union is providing
something that that that that employee
does not want in other words they don't
support the outcome of the bargaining
then why should they have to pay for
something that they didn't like would be
you I'll go with representative L Clair
and then
um thank you just kind of following up
on that if 99% of the people agree that
it's good for them wouldn't it be better
than just the 1% that may not I think
that the Crux the Crux of of the issue
is important of what you're raising and
that is and that is uh by ensuring that
unions get paid when their members
believe that the the outcome of the of
the negotiation is is something that's
supporting something that they support
and they'll voluntarily want to join the
unions and you'll have greater
participation if on the other hand uh
they think well we can get 51% to
support this and that's enough because
we're going to get agency fees from the
other 49% then I don't think that's good
for the for the overall health the
morale of of the bargaining
unit can I follow up okay please um and
these Agreements are made between not
just just um the workers but they're
also made between the businesses or the
people that they work for
again it's not it's typically not 51%
it's really high numbers in negotiations
I've seen some negotiations and it's
never just 50 plus one it's it's it's
really is it back and forth back and
forth back and forth and and again not
everybody's going to agree not you know
you got people that agree with you right
is this a question so so again I'm sorry
you're right um you know why does that
why would the
51% or 50% plus 1% even make a
difference I mean if if most of the
people that are out there agree to it
wouldn't that be I mean that's how we're
we elect officials and thank you for the
question I would say I would say that if
you look at some of the most effective
unions and I in particular I look at the
the public safety unions that have 99%
to your point 99% of the individual
members that means that the union is
absolutely providing something that they
find valuable and useful when you have
bargaining units that are significant
less than that I mean I I'll give you an
example as someone who was a former
state employee the state employee is
nowhere near that
99% uh then you have a number of people
who are dissatisfied with the outcome of
the
bargaining representative McKenzie Mr
chairman I have I'll have two questions
I can shoot them uh at this point uh
together uh could you explain to us what
the Americans for Prosperity is and
where you get your money and how you
funded sure sure absolutely uh Americans
for Prosperity is a 501c4 uh it means
we're we are on what the IRS describes
as a social welfare organization uh we
Advocate on behalf of policies that
expand economic freedom uh the second
question you ask is where we funded from
well we have over 500,000 donors across
the country including over 1500 here in
New Hampshire and they they pay their
dues because they think we do a good job
let me ask you another question if I
could Mr chairman uh yes follow but be
mindful we're we're going to have to
throw some people out of here without
speaking if we take up the time that
we've allotted to them this is this is
the opportunity I have to just so and I
to be honest with you I understand where
you're coming from but you know I a
little resentful of of the the position
you're taking I understand it but these
are this is our opportunity to question
people come before this I'm I'm just I'm
asking you to just be mindful not I'm
not saying I have you uh is can you tell
me uh if anytime you're a state employee
either you or anybody that you knew ever
turned down the benefits that were
negotiated by the local by uh
1984 well considering legally I don't
have the right to do that I would that
the answer is no is the answer no they
they they don't have the
option thank you are there further
questions representative Granger uh
excuse thank you for uh taking the
question uh excuse I I I don't have a
lot of experience working in a union um
the only experience I have was a bad one
and it didn't last very long but if so
let's say I'm working at a union job and
I don't like some aspect of what they've
negotiated so for instance I don't take
health insurance I don't believe in
health insurance um and I I would rather
have a different deal if it's a union
job and I'm not a member of the Union
how do I go about actually getting what
I
want well so and thanks for the question
uh I first in the first instance I'd say
that that um you don't have the right
legally assuming it's it's a certified
under the National Labor Relations Act
if it's a certified bargaining unit you
don't have the right to negotiate for
yourself that that is taken away uh
that's that's called exclusive
representation was part of the the
Wagner Act uh obviously you can go
outside obviously you can go outside of
of that and and either leave the
bargaining unit or the other opportunity
would be to to try to join the union and
change the direction of what where
they're
bargaining okay and if so uh uh
followup I'll I'll pass on the follow-up
questions thank you Mr Vice chair hello
Mr
Moore um would your organization have
the belief that it would be best for
American um businesses to just do away
with unions
completely for the libertarian leaning
bent of your
organization no uh thanks for the
question no uh we think that if people
want to un unionize and organize that is
absolutely fine and absolutely their
prerogative uh our big our big hangup is
really the ex the the uh requirement
that people who are not members of the
Union uh have someone else bargain on
their
behalf any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you
and um John if you can come up and say
your name and I won't Massacre it
again and after after this uh DJ
bluen uh Claudia Estelle and
representative Jr
hle thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
members of the committee and um
Everybody mask as my name so you're not
out of line um my name is John bonani
I'm a represent of the United Steel
Workers Union United Steel Workers union
represents a number of people and a
number of different Industries in the
Hampshire um from
manufacturing water
distribution um and utilities I I myself
came from a utility company from a local
union that represents people who work
and live in the Hampshire
Massachusetts um I work there for over
over 32 years in the field so I I know a
lot of the members firsthand and I know
a lot of the things that they deal with
and I know a lot of the benefits that
they receive a number of them are are
here today in the room um I can tell you
that our members come from all different
types of political Persuasions I there's
a lot of things that our members don't
agree on um and you know we deal with
with that every day but I can tell you
honest to
God
overwhelmingly they
adamantly do not like this type of
legislation and I could talk about all
the reasons why you heard a lot of the
good reasons that were already said that
I had PL to talk about um but it it
really comes down to they know how
important important a union job
is to their way of life and a decent way
of
living and we could have hundreds of
people come in here and talk about it
but I'm here on their
behalf and and I'm telling you that they
do not support this
legislation their families do not
support this
legislation and I respectfully ask that
you not support this so thank you if you
have any questions I'd be more than
happy to talk to you I'd actually be
more than happy to talk to you offline I
can leave a card with somebody but
please again on behalf of our members do
not support this thank you thank you for
questions uh yes if you could pass the
card around the clerk will put it in the
folder right
yeah thank
you um so next up DJ bluen uh
representing himself and the sheet metal
workers uh following that Claudia is
Estelle and representative Jr
hul good afternoon everybody yeah thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak to you all my name is DJ bluen and
I uh have a bit of a unique perspective
in that I am a union contractor and I I
am also a member and I employ these same
guys and I could sit and debate both uh
both sides of unionism very
impassionately and I can go down and
repeat all of the things that our
brothers and sisters have pointed out
here about the benefits that unionism
brings to them this bill that is before
us is here every two years it's never
passed and it's starting to become
irresponsible with legislator who are
being given this opportunity to shine by
people out of state because I don't know
who this law benefits in New
Hampshire
the things that have been discussed here
today can we can go on chapter and verse
about the benefits for workers and
people in the state New Hampshire is an
expensive place to live and you got to
stroke a big living to live here and
unionism provides the kind of wage
package and benefit package that allows
a middle class to thrive here in New
Hampshire unionism also and this is
something that hasn't been said and I
think that is
important unionism gives an attractive
option to young people who are not
college educated to stay in this state
the Navy Yard puts tremendous pressure
on that resource for us as contractors
and in order to retain any kind of young
capable willing people we need to offer
them more than just some Mississippian
or indianan or whatever right to work
state you can pick whatever Vision they
have for compensation we are in the
Northeast where it's tremendously
expensive to live I would urge lawmakers
here to find ways to reduce our
electricity tax I would ask you if you
are willing to develop the state
economically to take away the business
dividend tax if you want to get
businesses to come to New Hampshire I
would say if you need Revenue sell weed
at the liquor
stores
but no no I'm serious if you want to be
modern and think about how to run this
state trying to stifle wages and
opportunities for its citizens is a
terrible thing and it doesn't it doesn't
benefit anybody in the state so I urge
you that if this bill makes it that you
vote no and if the Senate Bill makes it
you vote no and this is someone speaking
to you from the management side of
Labor we work in Partnership okay it's
not the 1940s where everybody's fighting
we've created a safety culture in the
last 20 years in the business and
reduced accidents and unions have done
that you know the the positive things
that unions have brought to this country
like the weekend you know things like
that like a 40-hour work week we can go
on chapter and verse it's just wrong for
New Hampshire and I thank you for your
time and I will answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
and representative buudy thank you Mr
chairman uh I had someplace else to go
but I had to come back to ask a question
sure um thank you for coming today and
speaking from management side uh
somebody before you spoke about
performance now being from management
side do you feel that if all the members
belong to the same Union perform better
together and the performance overall is
better we ensure our performance in
trade unions by controlling our training
of our apprentices it's typically a four
or fiveyear program and every Apprentice
in a trade Union be it an electrician a
plumber a sheet metal work or a
carpenter they go to school at night or
they block out two weeks of school
during the work hours to have book
learning and to understand Concepts and
that's stuff that is all privately
funded by unions themselves when you pay
dues you pay into your training program
and the training program ensures that
the guys coming behind you are working
retire follow so this would if they're
all working and training together their
teamwork must be a much better our
productivity level is far higher than
any sheet metal worker that is not
organized thank you any further
questions thank you for your testimony
um now being after 4:30 I uh got some
instructions from chairman infantine one
of the issues that we have right now is
that the um house staff is going to be
kept over their time and and just at the
rate that we're going we can't possibly
get through all this testimony so
chairman infantine told me that he is
going to resume the hearing we need to
end between
5:15 uh maybe 5:30 at the very latest
and uh any any people we can't get to in
that time we're going to have to pick up
later and yes Claudia is still uh is
speaking for herself in opposition to
the bill followed by representative J.R
gonzal thank you for letting me speak
and um I stand in opposition to this
bill a lot of things have been said that
I was going to say so I want to just
share two things one um I'm a lifetime
member of Nea as a public school
educator and I'm also a member of SEIU
um 1984 chapter 32 as an adjunct in the
community college system um I've
benefited greatly from being a union
member um as a teacher one of the things
I love is when I get to see former
students and I ran into a former student
of mine in the grocery store young man
who was you know you know an average
student a nice guy he was so proud of
the fact that he had a great job a great
union job so that he was earning a good
living he was getting training he was
being able to put money aside for his
retirement as in as a young man in his
20s so that's one thing I want to say
and the second thing is as a teacher um
there were times when we when
negotiations when we were negotiating
our collective bargaining agreement
that we focused on um the particularly
the pay um for the younger teachers and
the newer teachers at the detriment
maybe of those who of us who were higher
up on the on the pay scale um who are
more experienced there were other times
that the reverse happened we had we done
things for people at the at the lower
end of the scale it was time to give
something to the people who were at the
top end of the scale
um I think it's because the thing that
that the gentleman from Americans for
Prosperity didn't point out is that
Union contracts are for the common good
and so I think that when we we we
negotiated those collective bargaining
agreements and sometimes one group
benefited more than another group we all
stood behind each together and
solidarity because we knew that this was
for the common good so that's all I had
to say thank you so much
questions and if you have a copy of that
that you can turn into the cler sorry it
was just notes all
right um so next up uh co-sponsor of the
bill representative J.R
hle thank he'll be followed by Jay Ward
Stefan Gonzalez and uh executive
counselor Cindy
warmington thank you Mr chairman for the
record represent resentative hle serving
the towns of Dunbarton hookit Allenstown
and
epom while I was sitting in the audience
I heard people talk about I was a member
of the Nea well given the recent US
Supreme Court decision right public
schools are not part of this anymore or
sorry public unions this is really about
private unions and the thing that comes
to mind is if the union has to work
harder for its membership to get the
donations as opposed to compulsory
membership the employees will better be
better off recently I had a a a job I
was having quoted for um that was a
plumbing job Plumbing there are Plumbing
unions there are private plumbers as
well plumbers are making or at least
billing north of $150 an hour if you are
a self-employed plumber You're Building
at $150 an hour what used to be rates
that you would see for engineers and
attorneys and higher-end firms are now
common in the trades and part of this is
due to a severe labor
shortage I think one of the things that
we need to think about is the unions
become more responsive to their members
once a right to work law is passed I
would ask that you would pass this thank
you thank you for your testimony are
there
questions seeing none thank you again um
next up uh Jay Ward representing himself
speaking in opposition to the bill
followed by Stefan Gonzalez uh Cindy for
inton and Joe
marusi thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Jay Ward and I am here in opposition to
House Bill
1377 and I'm representing myself
um I there's so many reasons why this is
bad for New Hampshire and let me just
say that 30 years ago I was in the state
legislature I sat in this committee we
heard the same exact Bill and it met
with the feet as it's done every two
years for the 30 years but the when I
was in it wasn't the first time that
this Bill had come up so it been there
for at least 10 15 years prior to that
and it had been defeated and I know that
we don't want to be repeating ourself
but I think we have to because we've
heard it all I mean everything that's
ever been discussed it's been discussed
and it's always been killed it's wrong
for New
Hampshire and I don't believe that you
all have had a lot of your
constituents coming up to you and saying
you know what the the the biggest thing
that you have to fix is Right to Work I
I don't believe that and so I
wonder I don't think there's another
bill out there that has
seen 40 Years of the same exact bill I
don't think that it's there but if it is
I'd like to see it and what you're going
to do about it but it just gives me
pause to say okay why is this bill here
I don't think it's it's generated from
constituents and so it must be
from National Right to Work committee
out of state that are giving money to to
legislators to bring this in I don't
know but one thing is really clear and
let's make no mistake this is an
anti-union bill there's no doubt about
it all these people that say oh it'll
make the union stronger it'll if you
want to help make Union stronger then
support them with jobs support them with
um ways to bring companies in to the
state rather than you know fighting
amongst the small percentages of the
workforce that are actually in the state
right let's face it it's not that
big and so imagine if in a world that we
spent as much
time that you've already spent on this
bill and many of you are multiple um uh
sessions have seen
it think about all the things you could
have been do doing like addressing the
the high energy cost like um adequate
afford housing adequate and affordable
daycare and education giving people the
the tools to get good jobs that will
attract businesses to the state not
having a artificial impediment to a um
uh a business to say you cannot
negotiate terms of your collective
bargaining that include a mandatory
um uh
dues if the owner of that business wants
to do that because he wants workplace
Harmony he is he or she has decided that
that's the way they want to go you're
going to say with this bill they cannot
do
it that's not in
the if you think about it why would you
even waste your time on that I mean let
the businesses do what they need to
do and give people real jobs that
will let them stay in this state you
know I um one of the things I I I
started to look back at all the bills um
that have come up on right to work in
the past and man I it's really tedious
it is so tedious to go through them all
and it just shows me
that you all can be be doing a lot of
things that's good for New Hampshire
this bill is not one of them
um I would say that
uh if you look at the bills that we've
been defeated
and the economy of this state has done
relatively well when you look at all 50
states but I can tell you it's doing a
heck of a lot better than if you compare
to just your right to work states
guaranteed there's there's no doubt that
you would be doing better so the world
did not end because we don't have right
to
work but yet you still spend so much
time on this
um and I mean while I like to come up
here and and talk to you all it's nice
to see all my brothers and sisters out
here I think we could be doing something
a lot better
and the one thing the irony of this
um unions are not corporations they're
not businesses and yet you had the one
of the sponsors of the bill come in and
say um try to equate
uh some business
model that's not what who unions are you
heard the um uh gentleman from uh
Americans for Prosperity talking about
unions as a business it unions are made
up of
members they decide what the uh um
direction of the uh Union wants to go in
they decide collective bargaining and
then they vote on it it's not a
business and also um the irony of of
some of this legislation and and some of
the uh supporters of it like the
chambers of the Commerce like um the Bia
they're all member organizations if you
would to say to them that they
suddenly um have to let everybody in and
they have to work for everyone the same
but they can't charge dues I don't think
they'd be very
happy but that's what this bill will do
and I know that you want to wrap it up
yes but then again I want to see you
wrap it up too and not have this come
year thank you for your testimony are
there
questions and then and we have yes go
ahead I'm gonna try to make this quick
great to see you again um it struck me
when you were with
sea um you brought it to my attention
that the membership of sea reflected a
political party membership in general
reflected the states membership and I
thought that was interesting and you've
worked with other unions um I know this
is probably true for the teamsters as a
granddaughter of a Teamster um I get the
sense that there's a disconnect between
um you know the National Organization
pushing this versus Republican union
members who um appreciate their Union
and in a way union membership can in
some cases create uh Republican Party
Loyalty in a way what was your sense and
what is your sense of the disconnect or
is there a disconnect um between like
Rank and file Republicans and Union that
are union members versus the national
cookie cutter bill um there is and just
like um in every single Community you
have what
30% uh Republicans 30% you know and so
it it's the same way we are a um exact
we are the the union is your community
because they're all the workers that are
combining together so there are going to
be um uh equal numbers of Independents
Democrats and Republicans um and it it
is all
local um and um what happens in DC
happens and so there is a great
disconnect any further
questions thankk for your time uh so I
would like to call Stefan Gonzalez uh
representing uh usw followed by Cindy
Hansen good afternoon Mr Speaker and
members of the committee uh not only am
I representing United St workers I'm a
20e plus resident of Salem New Hampshire
my name is Stephan gonzalves I have
lived and raised my family in Salem New
Hampshire for over 20 years during my
years living in Salem I've seen much
growth most of it for good new schools
new businesses housing was a nice place
to raise my
family for for also for those 20 years I
have also belonged to the United Steel
work is a union my first 30 plus
years I W I wasn't working for a union
and the difference is staggering raises
yearly Good Health Care job security
retirement all things we can count on my
union is also an Amalgamated Union and
we have over 200 members who live and
work in New Hampshire these are good
jobs with my position with the steel
workers I travel a lot and I meet a lot
of people a lot of brothers and sisters
from a lot of right to work
states and out of their mouths the first
words are we only we only we only
because we're a right to work state we
only why less pay worse health care
benefits no retirement higher Place work
injuries deaths no safety committees We
Are Better Than This New
Hampshire look at the right to work
states they are the poorest states in
the nation this is not a coincidence who
is pushing this in in New Hampshire not
not anyone in New Hampshire we are
better than this I will leave you with
this as an adver golfer I ask you how
many of you belong to a health club a
golf club a gun club maybe we can make
them right to work and everyone can use
them while you pay the fees again we are
better than this n sure thank you thank
you very much are there any
questions seeing seeing none thank you
again uh next up I would uh call
Executive counselor Cindy
warmington and that will be followed by
Kennedy thank you members of the
committee good afternoon my name is
Cindy warmington I live in conquer serve
as our state's executive counselor of
District 2 I come before you today
asking that each of you oppose any and
all efforts to bring so-called right to
work to the Granite State and more
specifically vote inexpedient to
legislate on this house bill
1377 unions built the middle class in
this country and they will rebuild it as
we fight for a brighter future for
Working Families the right to
collectively bargain is a fundamental
Freedom across the United States that
should be protected here in New
Hampshire so-called right to work laws
are simply Right to Work For Less that
they harm and disadvantage Working
Families the proposed legislation before
us which is veiled as maximizing
individual freedom of choice would
actually decrease wages increase unsafe
working conditions and reduce benefits
for working people across our our state
out of state special interests and
proponents of so-called right to work
laws have tried multiple times over the
last several decades to bring these
disastrous policies to our state and
thankfully New Hampshire has come
together to stop these attacks on the
middle class and each and every time we
value the hardworking Granite Staters
who keep our state moving forward we
understand that they are the backbone of
our economy and without them it would
come to a grinding halt in my two terms
on the executive Council I have
represented hundreds of thousands of
hardworking families across eight of our
10 counties from firefighters to
fishermen to teachers small business
owners from north to south and east and
west in small towns and big cities the
people of our state support workers and
their neighbors and their ability to
collectively bargain it is critical that
every employee in the state of New
Hampshire is able to work in safe
working conditions this legislation
undermines that it is critical that
every employee has good wages and good
benefits can access quality affordable
health care the legislation diminishes
workers Collective power to secure those
benefits it is harmful to Working
Families and to our communities right to
work is wrong for new New Hampshire and
again I urge each of you to vote in
expedient to legislate on this Bill
thank you thank you for your testimony
and if that's a written copy you can
provide to the clerk we'll submit it
electronically thank you thank you thank
you very much um any
questions seeing none thank you again uh
next I would call Joe marusi
representing himself in opposition to
the bill followed by Blaine Hansen John
chairperson committee thank you for the
time my name's Joseph
morazzi I live in New Hampshire uh I'm a
republican a lot of people before me
have gone against this I agree I go
against it as well I just have one
question seeing is this is Private
Business unions private entity has
anyone
thought this is kind of out of the
perview with the
government it's died in New Hampshire I
think this will be hopefully the 19th
time
and that wasn't a rhetorical
question to you guys has anyone thought
this is just a waste of time why are we
hearing this
again it's clearly something we don't
want and there are no sponsors of the
bill on this committee so uh someone if
if that's your full testimony maybe
someone wants to respond and I'll allow
that but uh I'll just say that I I agree
with you I think it's a waste of time
and yet I do enjoy seeing all the me my
brothers and sisters from labor is
pleasure thank you for your
testimony uh next I'll call Blaine
Hansen um in opposition to the bill
representing himself that will be
followed by John Kennedy representative
Mark Pearson and Lance
mazero I mess that one up didn't thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
uh my name is Blaine Hansen I live in
Pinardville um I am a union member I am
also president of Carpenters Local 352
in Manchester um and I am here to speak
in opposition to this legislation once
again um it seems every two years we
come back here um Americans for
Prosperity The Mao group couple others
show up throw campaign money around and
we're treated to another Right to Work
fight um there's plenty of stuff you
folks uh should be doing instead of
belaboring this again and again um we
have an aging State um we suffer from
brain drain um our cost of living is
ridiculous and there's not enough
careers in this state to sustain the
population there's plenty of jobs but
nothing where you can buy a house and
support a family and that's a problem um
so continuing the race to the Bottom by
enacting right to work which as other
people have said um is just anti-labor
legislation it's um union busting at its
best um and it's a waste of time for the
state um one thing I will say um there's
a lot of Labor people in here um I've
talked to all of them um at one time or
another I don't know if anybody in this
room that is uh forced to pay their dues
they all do it willingly and they like
what they get for it um you guys need to
do better you need to figure out why
companies that have good jobs and pay
good wages don't come to the state we
know workman's comp in the state's
ridiculous we know utility rates in the
state are ridiculous find out why
Massachusetts the state that some of you
complain about having high taxes and
high regulations and supposedly being
not business friendly is full of Fortune
500 companies and none of them come here
55 miles difference between my house and
where I work and I double my
income that's a problem in this state
and that's why young people leave and
that's why the state keeps getting older
and older and older and my last point is
I noticed everybody in this room that is
against this
legislation is dressed like this and has
work boots on everybody that supports
this legislation is from out of state
and is wearing a suit thank you very
much thank you for your testimony I'll
assume
there no
questions
um next I'll call John Kennedy who is
the president of Specialty Services of
New
England and that will be followed by
representative Mark Pearson uh Lance
bovo John John and I are going to speak
together I'm Lance maelo we work for the
same company oh
okay very good so I'm the president of
uh Specialty Services New England with
signatory to the carers union um we do
work all over New England um I've asked
Lance masello who is our uh director of
operations to speak on behalf of
specialty services in
langland I'm a union carpenter it's been
with uh The Marquees family of companies
which is the parent company to specially
serves in New England for the better
part of 15 years in a variety of roles
uh all told our companies are we're a
contractor based in Salem New Hampshire
I am a New Hampshire resident I live in
Derry New Hampshire with my wife and two
daughters um our company represents
about a, or 1200 is workers we one of
the largest Union subcontractors in the
country um and I I prepared this this
statement about how wrong this is and
and everybody has mirrored that
sentiment here I and I heard a lot of
numbers and I heard a lot of a lot of
different things and one thing I could
tell you is that you know what I do see
amongst the people that work for me is
home purchases I see health care I see
growing families I see uh additions to
quality of life I see Joy there's
there's a lot lot to be said about about
that and I don't see anyone um that is
in opposition to belonging the union I
contrary to that in my tenure here I
have helped I I I can't even count how
many people find a pathway to Union
membership not just in the Carpenters
but in various trades and other avenues
uh in other businesses and find their
own Prosperity I in in all my time here
I and the time I spent mentoring and
working and help help to bring
apprentices on I myself having been the
beneficiary of an apprenticeship um I've
I've never I've never had anyone come to
me and say you know I'm uh I'm being
forced to pay these dues and I don't
feel like I'm getting what I should I I
hate I'm going to tell you a quick
little story and I hate telling the
story because I hate using it um but my
my daughter levinia who was born in 2017
two months after being born suffered a
stroke um and uh thank God we're in New
England and we have the Health Care
system that we did we went to Mass
General Hospital and I want to tell you
after 150 days in the hospital I don't I
I couldn't even guess what the bills
would have been what it would have done
to the next decade of my life if I even
ever got out of that hole if it wasn't
for gold star health care that's
provided by collectively bargaining with
the union and the the ability for the
union to uh to do that now I I'm happy
to tell you today that my 6-year-old is
taking her Nea tests in kindergarten and
I'm expecting her to perform
admirably
um all right this is so much more than a
political issue you know we heard about
um the the third party in there which I
think is so absurd that we're not also
the consumers of the products that we
are providing um I I do all of my
shopping in New Hampshire like I I I
do I love this state I'm I was born in
New York in New York City I came here
because this state offered I that that
Live Free or Die culture um and and I
want that and I want to see that and we
need to we need to reject this with
every fiber of our
being thank you thank you for your
testimony any questions representative
Rudy thank you Mr chairman uh thanks for
your
testimony I know a little bit about the
Carpenters Union um we've heard a lot
about a lot of things but I know the
Carpenters Union don't just hire people
and put up to an appren program like an
OJT you have training centers can you
tell us who pays for the training
centers and and what how they
function so there there actually we have
a beautiful training C Center in uh
Manchester New Hampshire um and the
members pay for the training center um
the members pay for the m at when I
joined the union I I actually commuted
to a training center in Milbury
Massachusetts and stayed out there I as
some of our other Union brothers and
sisters uh testified earlier you know
nights and weekends and weeks at a time
to get the the requisite training hours
in to complete the apprenticeship um but
one of the one of the greatest
components of uh unionism is the ability
to upskill yourself you know I I think
the narrative in the media has been in
the last year that uh the current
generation can't afford healthare can't
afford College can't afford access to
the skills and the training that are
going to give them the ability to earn
what's going to be required to succeed
in the world that we see coming we're
we're so heavily invested in our people
and offering them the ability to get
those Next Generation skills that are
going to make them relevant Beyond today
um you have to be seeing the fact that
everything is changing and if you don't
have organizations responsible employers
that are committing to to put money into
building their people that that that is
a a zero sum game for uh for New
Hampshire residents like I love it here
I I love the the winters the summer the
weather the people I love it here and I
want to see this be a place where people
can keep coming I looked at the numbers
on um on right to work in in other
places and it's it's lower income it's
mortality on construction sites it's
less safety um it every metric that you
could measure this by I is is lower I
can't even understand why I'm back here
again and this I think this is my third
time now coming to talk to all of you
about this it's ridiculous it's an
interfer
in private business we should be
throwing this out on its heels it goes
against what we are as New Hampshire
thank you thank you for your Tes thank
you any other
questions seeing none thanks again um
next I'll call Representative Mark
Pearson representing
himself thank you Mr chairman I was
going to say I don't envy your job
except I actually do have your job and
I'm chairman of children and family law
committee chairman of the Department of
Health and Human Services oversight
committee and the chairman of the
special committee on the Family Division
of the circuit court but I am here today
as an old-fashioned traditional New
England
Republican this bill before us as we've
heard several times comes up about every
two years and gets shot down every two
years including terms when my fellow
Republicans had a significant majority
in the house well there's so many bills
that are filed every year that I don't
pay attention to every one of them and I
haven't paid attention to this one until
this year and when I read it I found
there are some things in it that Disturb
This old-fashioned traditional New
England Republican let me give you just
two one old-fashioned traditional New
England Republicans believe in
supporting business while we do know
that some business laws have their place
that would regulate safety and prevent
sexual harassment in general we don't
like the government telling us how to
run our businesses and this bill seeks
to regulate private businesses if I own
a business and I tell my employees they
must now we to work pink bib overalls
that is my right to do so if they don't
like it I don't ow them owe them a job
they can go to work elsewhere if the
public thinks I'm crazy they can shock
elsewhere or buy from other people you
don't like Walmart go to Target I don't
want the government's Fashion Police to
say I can't require them to wear the
uniform of my choice that is not
old-fashioned traditional New England
republicanism I want the minimum of
State interference with how my business
is run and this bill
interferes secondly I come from a large
family we've got at least one of just
about every C category of person you can
imagine in my family we've got a few who
truly need government assistance they
don't want a hand out and they're
willing to do their fair share but they
do need a hand up and I don't begrudge
that but we also had a chisler in the
family she could work but she wouldn't
she wanted to sit back and get a check
that comes out of all of our pockets and
I do resent that some company owners
like to have a union a good respectable
Union because they'd rather deal with
one Union bargaining team than a whole
lot of individuals and I've been told
that by numbers of company owners seems
to me if the union negotiating team has
spent time effort and money to represent
the workers to ownership everybody who
will benefit from the new contract
should contribute to the costs incurred
to get them a raise in pay and
benefits it would be a chisler who would
take the raise in income and benefits
but not help pay the share that is fair
now no one should be required to pay
into a union political action committee
including one that might support
me I believe it's against the law anyway
but we're not talking here about
political action committees we're
talking about better pay and benefits un
unless someone's willing not to take the
negotiated pay raise or donate it back
to the company I think they need to pay
their fair share I wonder also how many
owners are willing to negotiate
separately with a large number of
individuals coming in one at a time well
being a chisler taking benefits while
not owning responsibilities is not to me
old-fashioned traditional New England
republicanism so Mr chairman and members
of the
committee I wrote this before I heard
two hours of testimony I don't know why
others may be opposed to this bill but
here's why I am I'm an old-fashioned
traditional New England Republican and
this bill doesn't sound like that to me
thank you for hearing my testimony and
because I'm running very late and so are
you I would uh choose not to take
questions fair enough thank you thank
you for your testimony thank you Mr I
yes um next up I would call David Bobo
uh Gen X Construction
forp okay so
that and so uh Kim hackinson of North
Carpenters thank you very much um it's
Kim Hokinson um I am uh the North
Atlantic states Regional Council of
Carpenters regional manager for Northern
New England so I cover main Vermont in
New Hampshire um I do have written
testimony and I will submit but I'll
just keep it short because I think we've
heard a lot um I am here representing
the North Atlantic states uh we
represent 30,000 or 30 30,000 Carpenters
across seven states up here in New
Hampshire we have approximately 2,500
Carpenters um we strongly oppose this
legislation
um we ask you to vote uh to not send it
through and if there's any questions I'd
be happy to take them but again I think
everyone understands that we oppose this
vly it's not good for our workers it's
not good for communities and it's not
good for our businesses as you heard
earlier thank you thank you for that
testimony are there any
questions seeing none I'll call Rob
Plunkett representing himself in
thank you and good evening dear
congressman and congresswoman I'm here
to oppose House Bill 1377 the so-called
Right to Work bill my name is Robert
plunket I am currently the recording
secretary for interior systems local 352
of the North Atlantic State's Carpenters
Union I currently reside in Northfield
New Hampshire and have called New
Hampshire home since
1995 I graduated Pinkerton Academy in
1997 and got married shortly thereafter
I went on to college during which time I
had two
children life as you can imagine was
quite difficult to balance I eventually
divorced and remarried and had another
child by 2008 I was having to work two
jobs to barely pay our bills with little
to no benefits or retirement options I
had to apply for food stamps and
financial assistance in May of 201 12 I
lost my primary job then in August of
2012 I lost my second job when Stop and
Shop closed all their stores in New
Hampshire at this time I decided to find
a job that would provide better pay and
benefits and allow me to actually be
home to be a father to my children I
worked through a temp agency while
applying to the Carpenters Apprentice
program I was accepted and began work on
forget sorry lost my
place uh since joining the Brotherhood I
have begun a most rewarding career I am
making two to three times more money
than I ever have I have a great benefits
in retirement package as well my family
is able to get the medical services they
need if right to work is passed in the
state of New Hampshire all these goals
and achievements and dreams will be
shortlived and
vanish at its core right to work is an
assault on unions inaccurately displayed
as an initiative to enhance worker
Freedom its true objective is to
unions financially by eliminating the
obligation for workers in a collective
bargaining Union to share the cost
associated with negotiation and
representation it's no hidden fact that
in other states where right to work was
passed wages and benefits eventually
dropped leaving many hardworking
Americans fearing for their
Futures not a single not a single state
in the Northeast currently enforces a
right to work
law despite persistent Endeavors by
special interest groups this legislation
has consistently faced defeat in our
state this pattern not only shows how
wrong right to work is for New Hampshire
but also the useless nature of investing
time and resources in its
Pursuit such resources could be better
used to help with other more pressing
issues such as opioids and improved
housing I ask you from the bottom of my
heart to please consider my testimony
and others along with the facts very
carefully then vote no on House Bill
1377 the so-called Right to Work Bill
thank you thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none and at this point
again there's still a lot of testimony
to go and we're up against a limit in
terms of the how staff able to support
um um this continuing so I'm going to
stop the testimony at this point we're
going to continue the hearing on this
bill at a time it it's up to the
chairman of the committee to um figure
out when we can schedule that and I do
apologize for anyone who's who's waited
here and hoped to testify today um but
we just ran short of time thank you very
thank